pfff
[Musique]
tu as vu ce qui se passe à toulouse a
nom de coutume par l'intérêt de quoi la
radio ou la télé les journaux tout le
monde en face à le truc mais oui ce
matin chez lui au précis m'attend mais
tout moment pas à l'autre c'est foutu
c'est que j'ai eu trois candidats
fantoches à reparler aussi leur mot à
dire que tout le monde encore chers amis
ses ennemis bonsoir bienvenue sur le
plateau de tout le monde en parle et
vous connaissez le principe tout le
monde en parle alors tout le monde en
parle très bien
vous connaissez les qui bat céline
d'armes
m
[Musique]
et
tu peux
oh la république tu es chaud aujourd'hui
un touché alors j'accueille maintenant
celle qui avec une pièce au splendid la
saison dernière s'est révélée être une
grande actrice que l'on compare
désormais à jacqueline maillan jackal
michèle bernier
ces derniers bons soirs quand l'at elle
s'appelle le démon de midi
oui dit mon milieu la dernière c'était
fou comme c'est linda et mais je suis
ravi de rencontrer
on va attaquer on va commencer le nom
solidaire entre canton et deux filles
ensemble souvent alors oui donc c'est le
démon de midi au splendid c'est un gros
gros succès 1 mais hélas vous êtes en
tournée mais je pars dans toute la
france par exemple par exemple nous
devons quand même pas aller dvico
connais pas alors oui en belgique
je ne connais pas non je pars à lille
lens lyon dijon bourg les valence dont
l'avon sait plus quoi enfin bon bref on
aura lieu sur la la france jusqu'au mois
d'avril
voilà on va en reparler mise à part
michèle bernier nous recevrons ce soir
renaud muselier
non
millau
[Musique]
alors vous savez que tout le monde en
parle on n'est diffusé que trois fois
par mois
franchement on se demande alors donc la
semaine dernière il avait pas de tout le
monde en parle donc le best-of que je
vais vous montrer maintenant c'est celui
de la semaine d'avancé donc le zapping
de l'émission numéro trois et ça
s'appelle tout le monde en a parlé
magnéto serge s'il vous plaît est ce que
je veux est ce que vous trouvez ça bien
de mentir
oui j'adore c'est génial c'est utile et
un plus bas à 110 ou moins mon métier
génial de mentir ben on essaye de voir
si j'ai pas une mouche non c'est sa
toute façon au massage compléments
capillaires uniquement alors c'est pour
ça je te demanderai de toucher
uniquement cette partie là je te
remercie quelles sont les armes de
séduction que vous déployez consciemment
le regard au bout
moi aussi charasse et aunis c'est madame
char a fait quelque chose
mais sheila tranquille donc avec des
shows 6,7 beckham ozil comment s'opère
la paix même châssis son habitacle
méfiez-vous est-ce que tu serais choqué
si je sortais avec ta fille
c'est une question ou une information
formation c'était dans les affres de la
semaine d'avant
il était un peu masqué nager la question
des vies parce qu'ils se demandait
c'était hier du côté du lard ou du
cochon en connaissant elissa ne pouvait
mener du lard ou du cochon
alors alors le démon de midi donc c'est
après la bd de florence cestac mais un
et vous l'avez montée avec une fille qui
est qu'à beaucoup de talent dans le nom
est imprononçable qui s'appelle marie
pascale osterrieth osterrieth avec quand
vous le dites vous ça va mieux ça va
tout de suite dit oui c'est mon ange
gardien
oui alors c'est qu'est-ce qui a lu la bd
la première c'est vous c'est elle assez
simple elle avoue je cherchais moi
depuis longtemps une pièce pour être
seul en scène et j'en ai donc écrit ce
pas peut-être cinq en 2002 j'ai mis à la
poubelle
et puis en fait le thème
de la femme de 40 ans délaissé m'a
semblé un bon thème parce qu'à chaque
fois j'en parlais tout le monde avait
une histoire me racontez là dessus donc
voila quoi
oui l'histoire donc c'est l'homme qui
quitte sa femme pour une plus jeune
c'est vrai c'est rare quand plus vieille
oui d'abord si michel sordi n'at elle
pas plus vieille que lui
non mais pas m c'est rare et très riche
trader
alors effectivement il ya une phrase qui
résume tout à fait le démon de midi
c'est toi tu es la femme de ma vie mais
elle c'est autre chose c'est une fait
voilà mais elles sont 25 ans bible quand
on tirait cela fait en fait s'appelle la
fée [ __ ] oui je trouve que ça lui va
plutôt bien parce que généralement on
est assez un peu indulgent avec les
jeunes filles quoi c'est vrai mais c'est
vrai que les hommes aujourd'hui très
régulièrement des hommes quittent une
femme de leur âge ou qu'ils ont épousé
avant de devenir son épouse est une
femme qui était resté avec eux dans
l'ombre que ces hommes finissent par
réussir professionnellement puis quand
ça va il dit celle-là ça fait déjà 10
ans ou quinze ans que je raconte mes
trucs qu elle m'énerve parce que je me
connais par coeur donc je vais raconter
mon histoire à une plus jeune qui
évidemment est complètement baba et qui
dans 10 ans sera plaquée de toute façon
je leur signale mais c'est ok y'a pas
aussi le fait que les pousse parfois se
laisse un peu aller une fois qu'elle est
casé c'est aussi le cas chez les hommes
halak allan a brisé les villages on peut
se dire que le laisser-aller dans un
couple est commun généralement parce
qu'au bout de quelques années c'est vrai
que bon on fait moins attention
généralement plus attachés au physique
ajoute réaction que
les femmes sup un non sens qu'avant
avant tout cas c'est pas la famille
c'est dire qu'avant l'homme il
il avait dépassé il avait des maîtresses
là on rester en famille carrément
wissant vont enfin il faut des fois on
peut les pousser parce qu'il aimerait
bien avoir le beurre l'argent du beurre
première alors la nouvelle qu'elle est
ce que c'est pas drôle non plus pour la
nouvelle parce que la nouvelle elle a
quand même elle à la pension alimentaire
à payer c'est à dire qu'il faut quand
même les une partie de l'argent du
nouveau ménage
yann ouvert jeu-là plaindrai pas avant
non
après l'école de temps en temps ils
ramènent les gosses elle est obligée de
se faner dexia n'avait qu'à prendre un
libre ah ouais d'accord par michel
delebarre de mariage et non avec apprend
il ya des mecs tout seul y en a plein
les petites âmes a une super mec déjà
divorcé en plus pourraient aller en
chercher à faire briser un ménage studio
naughty tellement non franchement à
l'ancienne qu'est-ce qu'elle fait
l'ancienne femme elle peut flore et
serré les dents à l'ancienne elle pleure
elle rage l envie de se venger mais
c'est très difficile de se venger et à
qu'au cinéma qu'on y arrive
et puis après c'est dit bon allez je
vais reprendre du poil de la bête quand
même et puis je vais aussi faire comme
lui que j'ai prendre des amants bon
alors le problème c'est où les trouver
quoi parce que c'est un petit peu
curieuse et histoire on parle que de ça
que d'amour et de se retrouver tous mais
personne ne se retrouve jamais vraiment
sale c'est vrai qu'à pas d'endroit n'y a
pas de l'électronique comme disent les
copains et entre en compte un tournage
avec un gosse en plus quand il va faire
moi personnellement tout va bien je vis
avec l'équipe de france 2 mais dites-moi
quand vous dites que la l'ancien elle
doit serrer les dents et sourire essayé
de serrer les dents et de sourires
pouvoir c'est dur quand même vrai alors
c'est quand même cette pièce je les dis
en commençant une grosse surprise parce
que c'est vrai que c'est pas un one man
show faut dire aux gens un c'est pas des
sketches les uns après les autres c'est
une vraie pièce c'est une pièce vous
êtes seul sur scène mais ce n'est pas un
one woman show je dirais pour vexer
personne et on vous avez vu sur scène
avec les avec
avec les filles mais là vous êtes la
première fois seul et comme je le disais
on découvre vraiment tout le monde l'a
dit une actrice plutôt que la rigolote
de service qu'on avait l'habitude de
voir
depuis le petit théâtre de bouvard puis
dans d'autres émissions et chez arthur
et le bonheur est permanente cette
question les l'aiguillé et autant dans
le rouge
quoi c'est on rigole du début à la fin
bon je le dis j'ai pas fait fortune en
jeu c'est la gardant les gens donc quand
je disais quand je dis quelque chose
comme ça j'imagine et vous me croyez ah
bon je croyais et non bon alors
et puis le théâtre ça vous branche rubis
4c mes premières amours je pense que
c'est l'endroit où je suis plus heureux
c'est sur scène quoi il se passe un truc
entre moi et le public
mais je réagis bien ouais la dernière
c'était ben oui j'ai pratiquement joué 1
entre le palais des glaces et et le
splendide et là c'est reparti on va
tourner et j'espère revenir à paris
après voilà volontiers donc ça s'appelle
on va reparler toute façon parce qu'on a
beaucoup parlé des hommes des femmes ce
soir tout ça là tout ce qui vous
intéresse vraiment il ya qu un sujet
c'est quand même l'amour
ben oui c'est moi j'ai 25 ans
aujourd'hui donc je suis un peu michel
et non non ça dépend bien de dire aux
hommes mariés mais est-ce que vous
pensez que par exemple
quand j'aurai 40 ans enfin quand les la
nouvelle génération aura 40 ans aux 45
ans vous pensez qu'on subira les mêmes
désillusions
ah oui oh oui mais non ça y est c'est
par ici que ça alors nous ce qui va se
passer à mon avis est que nous les
femmes on va de plus en plus vous
plaquer oui voilà nouvelle ça c'est très
fort c'était pas changer maintenant
propos juste pour aller 5 boss tout
volontiers pour illustrer nos propos je
vous propose qu'on regarde un extrait du
spectacle le démon de midi de michèle
bernier magnéto serge s'il vous plaît il
avait su brésil juillet toutes les
bonnes femmes de moins de 30 ans et
encore même 2 à l'aller quoi se méfier
aussi pauvre que leurs mirobolantes
parce que moi je le sais la pousse guère
l etat puis non
la niche aux aguets bondir sur le modèle
d'un problème c'est qu'on leur fallait
pas tout de suite il a parce qu'elles
sont tous les genres qui est pourquoi tu
me direz vous pascal de stella ça peut
brûler elle ne sait que ça va être
facile que le mal est pas douter les
meilleurs gauchers la fois comme outil
dans la même poêle est un ratage et de
même mère voilée mois sa langue il a
envie d'entendre de la bouche icônes et
une poupe les brouilles intelligente
qu'elle attendait énorme sécurisant et
que bien sûr il est le premier homme à
la rendre heureuse
les couleurs à ses postions qui font les
fiers c'est un plan qui dénude matinée
du cerveau leur vie nobel il n'oublie
lieux raconté qu'à son anniversaire 9 un
karaoké qui l'a chanté sur scène
[Applaudissements]
michel dernier on arrive pascale
osterrieth d'après la bd j j * d'après
la bd de florence cestac qui s'appelait
pareil de changement d'herbage réjouit
les veaux avec ça c'est génial c'est
bien ce changement d'herbage réussi
c'est vrai la vitamine haute opinion de
vous à ces canards bon alors maintenant
on va faire un essai que chaque semaine
comme ça j'invente un peu des nouvelles
interviews alors là je vous ai réservé
une interview assez c'est une interview
à l'envers mais pratique
attention bougeait pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors est-ce qu'on peut baisser un petit
peu la lumière s'il vous plaît donc
l'interview à l'envers c'est très très
simple je vous donne la réponse et vous
me donnez la question alors allons-y
je vous donne un nom comme ça voulait
dire la question qui aurait pu nous y
amener arthur fait attention à ce que
vous dites mans alors je vais la faire
gentil qu'elle est l'animateur qui
m'appelle moumoune en ils vous appellent
moumoune ouais pas ce gentil c'est vrai
nous on peut par exemple et 6 mai le
surnom je suis donné tellement cochon
qui se dit et ppda quel animateur que la
même voie qu yves lecoq
ouais chazal clair qu'ils émettent
l'animatrice qui ne parlent jamais un
week end
ah oui la gaffe qui est née matters qui
a des bras ouais ce qu'on les voit
toujours bien l'homme de l'année l'année
non qualité de la télé c'est public a
voté sabatier sur un rocher qui est
l'émetteur qui sera rocher maintenant
gildas s'essuie tu trouves toujours un
petit boulot à canal il a j'arrête bus
d'ailleurs je crois à son nom mireille
dumas
l'animatrice dont j'aimerais avant la
permanente
oui laurent bignolas alors lui je les
aime beaucoup et ce alors est ce que
vous aimez laurent bignolas
je crois qu'il chausse du 42 c toi là je
sais tout le monde aime bien laurent
bignolas
faut pas rever quoi c'est ça thierry
ardisson qui élit matière qui invente
des interviews voilà merci donc vous
restez avec nous jusqu'à la fin
d'émission merci je vous garde
je vais accueillir maintenant un homme
politique que j'ai découvert un jour en
rentrant chez moi sur lci moi je mets
beaucoup lci passe comme si sur la rue
en fonctionnalités sur lci puis je
m'étouffe en est ainsi parce que ça me
donne l'heure surtout puis 4,40
il ya des réveils à maintenant c'est
important d'avoir le cac 40
donc je les ai vus se relire cet homme
politique un et j'ai dit les formidables
et j'ai dit à catherine barma est-ce
qu'on pourrait pas l'inviter alors on
l'a invité il est là on me je connais
pas plus que ça vous non plus
il s'appelle renaud muselier vous pouvez
embrasser les menaces est compris dans
le sait qu'on prie dans le circuit
touristique et moi là bas puis aussi oui
mais c'est normal pour une fois qu'il ya
une politique jeunes voilà il embrasse
linda attention je suis content on me
dira au régime vous êtes très beau oui
bah tant mieux il a étrillé d'avoir un
électorat féminin ça peut servir
donc on va brosser un petit peu votre
portrait et 40 ans vous êtes marié 4
enfants médecins spécialisés dans les
traumatismes crâniens ce qui est parfait
après le score du rpr aux européennes et
vous êtes spécialisé dans les réveils
des comateux aussi ce qui est tout à
fait bien aussi pour le rpr parce qu'on
peut pas dire que le parti se porte très
bien vous demande pas d'être d'accord ou
pas d'accord non c'est moi formation
médicale havrais pour le rpr c'est vrai
qu'on a pris un coup donc si on peut se
servir de mon expérience médicale pour
refaire marcher notre fonctionnement on
peut pas faire de la sela il faut
vraiment être fort parce qu'il faudrait
suscité le panonceau m'envoyer une
travail alors cette députée des
bouches-du-rhône premier adjoint au
maire de marseille
monsieur gaudin le 26 juin un
électrochoc vous décidé de vous
présenter à la candidate à la présidence
donnez votre candidature à la présidence
est ce que chirac était au courant non
vous avez fait ça sans l'accord de
monsieur jacques chirac jeu oui il
paraît bon ben alors ça va non à la
réalité ça n'a pas voulu chiffrer à moi
je suis chiraquien n'est plus la
première heure j'aime chirac je
m'entends bien avec lui j'ai un grand
respect pour lui je les ai toujours
soutenu c'était le président du
mouvement politique c'est le président
de la république aujourd'hui mais comme
vous l'avez dit j'ai 40 ans je suis
marié j'ai quatre enfants et vous ferez
obligé à 40 ans la norme a pris pas
besoin de demander à maman de sortir le
soir c'est déjà demain donc je fais ce
que je dois faire pour mouvement
politique alors vous avez été le premier
c'est vrai que le 26 juin vous étiez le
seul à vouloir être président du rpr
puis deux puis il ya eu quand même un
certain nombre de gens il ya deux le
voyais à fillon et alliot marie et
devedjian mais vous êtes persuadé que la
fin vous serez 3 sinon delevoye et vous
non je pense que c'est la femme qui
saute
oui c'est la présidentielle se fait
sauter ses salines à garder à la parité
on n'est pas du tout avec des garçons
michel omari oui mais il paraît qu'elle
vous dites ok on sera où sera
vraisemblablement d'après des
informations là je pensais pas qu'on
aurait tous les signatures de filles en
bas d'une jupe françois les devedjan les
lycées signature finalement je sais pas
encore mais apparemment il est en train
d avoir été à 1850 voudrait pourra
passer la barre bon alors nous vous
voilà présenter maintenant ce qu'on peut
dire si vous n'êtes pas aidé par le rpr
ils ont dit le 26 juin quand vous êtes
déclaré ils ont dit il s'est tiré une
balle dans le pied
pas très sympa quand même je continue à
courir à rennes je n'aime pas me citer
une balle en caoutchouc donc ça rebondit
d'accord c'est sympa les rapports au
sein de ces nouveautés
voilà c'est des gens qu'ils ont peur de
participer à l'appel de 50% bien
pensants un malheur toutes les campagnes
il s'en fait pour qu'on vote est
derrière vous arriver et c'est sous son
charme
le pire c'est béraud qui fait le mariole
la fée 9% alors je suis un vilain petit
canard la machine national du rpr est
contre moi ça c'est ce que vous avez
déclaré
et alors ils vous font des coups tordus
quand même parce que vous avez reçus une
lettre de pandraud qui s'occupe de la
campagne de deux le voit chez vous c'est
à dire qu'ils ont piqué le fichier du
rpr et que vous l'avez pas le fichier du
rpr
bah oury la dune écrire parce qu'il
pensait qu'il pouvait peut-être me
convaincra ses idées mais sérieux
renault ça vous énerve pas son tout ça
ce sont des vieilles méthodes tous à
fond de secours il faut mettre un peu
d'oxygène il faut dépoussiérer tout ça
donc quand vous avez vous entreprenez
une démarche comme la mienne qui est une
démarche qui est de dire bien maintenant
il faut qu'il y ait un débat politique
il faut que plusieurs candidats il faut
que tout le monde s'exprime et puis on
verra bien les militants qui décideront
qui vont vraiment c'est forcément ceux
qui ont des habitudes du passé
vous savez peut-être je conviens que
gens de gauche à voter pour moi mais
vous avez bien commencé il ya on dit
voilà ça va être la démocratie tout le
monde va vouloir va pouvoir se présenter
que bout d'un moment c'est suite
chiraquie et qua non mais oui alors bord
pas forcément gênant si avant les gens
ont pu s'exprimer présenter des choses
différentes s'expriment et voter tous
ensemble ce qui n'a jamais été le cas
parce qu'ils combattent tout le monde
s'exprime de la sorte il à 90%
enfin c'est quand même pas le même
méthode démocratie enfin pas tout à fait
une chose c'est pas le même genre le
pays et de façon non une obligation de
faire une révolution culturelle dans
notre mouvement politique lac si on ne
fait pas eh bien on continuera à avoir
des défaites électorales des gens qui ne
vont plus voter des déceptions
ils sont devenus on est triste c'est
vrai les choses avant de revenir je veux
faire une parenthèse renault avant de
revenir sur nos affaires du rpr vous
avez déclaré de façon j'aime pas paris
donc c'est vrai que vous n'êtes pas vous
la jouer un peu province que c'est un
peu votre positionnement les élites
parisiennes le microcode par exemple
vous mettez un petit peu en dehors oui
mais c'est vrai que nous marseillais on
n'est pas fondamentalement en phase
aller les parisiens on n'est pas en
phase a le pouvoir central on a toujours
été en porte-à-faux on est pas on n'est
pas copains que ce soit dans le foot ce
soit ça soit en politique ça soit réglé
n'a que ce soit avec les castes avec les
élites avec la météo qui était le plus
beau chant mais ceci étant cela pas venu
à marseille pour tap annoncé jusqu'à
marseille en 94 vision même pas manquer
demain 14 était fracturé la mâchoire et
ouvrir le crâne par des dockers qui
manifestaient oui mais les docteurs donc
il s'en fout oui on s'en fout j'aimerais
faire soigner se faire soigner les
autres
en 96 cents 94 sur ces dangereux d'être
de faire la politique à marseille en 96
gestion d'autoroutes avec votre voiture
de fonction il ya une roue qui se
détache sur la double
surtout quand il ya la femme et enfants
dans la voiture ça fait ça fait pas
plaisir famille 97
il ya deux ans environ trouver une pile
dans votre moteur qui devait chauffer
[ __ ] le feu au moteur extérieur
ouais c'est dangereux si c'est difficile
de pouvoir toujours s'exprimer avec ses
convictions et son caractère quoi vous
êtes attaqués aux bandits là bas non non
non non rassurez moi vous êtes à quel
point la mafia au point de lui ce que je
penserais forcément ça j'aime bien alors
on revient sur les repères seule
question donc j'ai envie de vous poser
c'est pourquoi il ya six candidats et
pourquoi se donner autant de mal pour
être le club théâtre en 20 parties aussi
pourri non mais non mais franchement
bien non mais sa formule n'a pas écouté
cette usereau quoi lui s'est plaint pas
non mais lui c'est pas franchement tu
aimes bien élastique âgées habran excuse
moi mais je suis la fille michèle cotta
de temps en temps quand je dis des trucs
donc j'aime mon mouvement politique
il est en difficulté je pense que nous
avons notre pays gouvernés par la gauche
est mal gouverné
je voudrais qu'ils sont gouvernées par
la droite ça passe par un appareil
politique aussi mal gouvernées par la
droite et il n'y a pas de raison pour
que cet article mal gouvernés par la
gauche autant l'être ceci étant robert
oui chérie hier soir bien un premier
album qui sort face aux liquidités deep
delevoye qui avaient été invitées mois
non non pas du tout parce qu'il ya eu
une première qui était faite avec des
amis de jacques chirac
un nouveau il y avait de le voir mais
moi j'étais à manchester united donc
foot et j'ai fait j'avais à faire je
suis allé alors vous avez dit je roule
pour chirac comme je l'aï toujours fait
chirac je l'aimais c'est un truc qui me
surprend toujours été les chiraquiens
c'est que voulaient les messins peu
inquiétant c'est quand même si vous lui
l'aimé comme ça là parce que c'est un
homme bon un homme de coeur un homme de
caractère et de tempérament c'est
l'homme fidèle et je pense que dans la
vie c'est sont des valeurs très
importantes
bon vous êtes surtout dans la vie
politique ça manque beaucoup plus zen je
dis pas qu'il est maintenant je dis
simplement quand j'entendis certains
politiques je laime ça c'est la porte
ouverte à tous les césarisme
enfin en attendant je suis autonome
ouais vous êtes à ce qu'on appelle être
fidèle et loyal pour vous est ce qu'on
appelle un bébé chirac on peut l'appeler
comme ça un bébé chirac
c'est un bébé chirac renom dollars
un adolescent cher ouais alors bon
imaginez quand même un truc mais
imaginez bon là vous donner du mal vous
avez un discours on vous êtes vous
remarque la presse quand vous invitez
vous avez la pêche non mais c'est vrai
je dis pas ça et puis imaginez que
chirac à un moment 10
bah écoutez vous appellent renault monti
renault un bond au nom des grands
principes du rpr votre grand père tout
sans m'en parler
je vous demande de vous désister pour
delevoye faites quoi vous mais je
discute ouais j'ai combien de temps je
raccroche à un jacques salue l'homme qui
a dit non comme un suggère linda hardy
les contacts que j'ai eus avec lui sont
des constats qui sont des contacts
privés à différents soutiens des autres
candidats en permanence se disent j'ai
téléphoné lisez juin la secrétaire la
secrétaire mardi qu'il fallait faire ça
c'est quand on sait même pas qu'ils ont
lu ce même pack isolé - je dis rien j'ai
le ratio que j'ai et je fais ce que j'ai
à faire comme sa maman défendre qu'il
est marrant non
et très sympa franchement vous êtes
alors maintenant verser du rpr la salle
est moins sympa parce que vous nous
expliquer ce que c'est le rpr parce que
où c'est un parti de droite libérale un
européen et à ce moment-là ça s'appelle
l'udf
ou alors c'est un parti national
républicain social et à ce moment-là ça
s'appelle le rpf alors expliquez-moi
leur voix si nous on merci
qu'est ce que c'est leur père dans les
repères vous avez des gens comme
devedjian qui sont des libéraux dont
comprends pas pourquoi ils sont pas
l'udf et vous avez des gens comme pasqua
qui a fait le rpf parce que lui voulait
défendre un côté plus social républicain
national lorsque vous êtes tous là
moi je n'aime pas mais voilà non mais
c'est difficile à accepter
oui parce que le parti gaulliste et un
parti qui est assez unique en ont
d'ailleurs de par l'histoire de la
france car de par son histoire
alors il est très facile à définir parce
gaulliste parce que ça max banon s'était
alors sur lui la démarche général de
gaulle j'ai voulu j'en attendais vous
quelqu'un de 25 ans molly ça vous dit
rien aux pays non mais parce que c'est
très facile admet musicale bonapartiste
approprié oui mais c'est une réalité
petit c'est une vraie difficulté pour
nous parce que ceux qui ont vécu la
guerre ça ce que c'est les enfants de la
guerre ils savent ce que c'est les
autres qui savent pas et pour eux c'est
une c'est une histoire très proche n'est
pas content pour elle c'est moins de 50
ans ça m'a jamais ce qui se passe et ils
n'ont pas tout à fait réaliser que ça a
été la démarche d'un grand homme d'une
force considérable issus de tous les
tempéraments politique d'ailleurs
n'est-ce que c'était par aliment est bon
et ça pour le définir notamment attaqué
en troisième millénaire
oui mais vous avez manqué le troisième
face à ce mouvement c'est difficile
notamment pour les jeunes
ça c'est clair ce qui va vous arriver
quand vous parlez trop si nous embarquer
dans les discussions moi je suis ravi
d'y couper
ça ou alors je vous pose un geste on
peut mosaïque et renault pendant dix ans
je refuse bon les secrétaire national du
rpr pour les questions de sécurité sur
la sécurité vous être plus dure que
la gauche c'est comme le maire de
numéros en 06 samu social j'avais qu'il
est tolérance zéro donc si quelqu'un ici
à de la drogue sur lui cacher le mage en
regardant on fait attention parce que
c'est tolérance zéro
je vous dis tolérance zéro bon alors sur
le revend à zéro parce que vous avez
vous avez une des petits gestes de la
vie quotidienne en ce qui concerne les
agressions des petits tout qui rendent
la vie tout parfaitement désagréable
pour tous nos concitoyens et que si on
pouvait avoir un système qui nous
permette d'avoir immédiatement une
sanction vous faites par quand vous êtes
pris parce qu'au départ la ceinture vous
pouvez payer tout de suite votre amende
vous pouvez vous savez que à nouveau
point qui sautent vous avez vous est
pris tout de suite mais c'est exactement
la même chose en ce qui concerne tous
les petits gestes de délinquance qui
nous pourrissent la vie au quotidien
mais c'est ça quelque part la proche de
ma conception de la société parle d'une
vie ça veut dire qu'il ya soixante dix
sept mille policiers en permanence qui
nous surveillent en errance d'accord
c'est ça oui ça on est payé par tous non
mais sûr que non vous respectez les
joints par exemple diction qui a des
caméras je suis sûr que là il craque il
n'a certes pas du flicage
c'est un respect de la loi je voudrais
pas vous faire passer pour un pour un
type de droite extrême
parce qu'en fait lui il a hissé dès vous
avez enlevé votre candidat à vitrolles
en 96 ans que la gauche serait lui non
front républicain quand même il a en
plus je suis le premier à voir mathieu
c'est vrai sa folie voilà on vous tient
dans ma circonscription le front
national choisi au départ 44 pour ça oui
très bien tous les cas vous exprimer
clairement la dernière chose c'est sur
les 35 heures alors là vous avez dit un
truc c'est assez bien nous expliquer
vous avez dit le partage du temps de
travail tel que le veut aubry c'est le
premier café ça c'est philippe pétain à
vichy en 40
non mais c'est vrai quand vous avez j'ai
fait sortir tout l'un tout l'hémicycle
sam nationale à gauche comme j'ai fait
ce que j'ai fait comparaison ils sont
tous partis qu'on leur avait dit ça a
mis au jour les bons ils ont hurlé sur
le riz sont sortis rester là vous à
gauche et oui j'ai comparé la
présentation du texte de l'oat sous
pétain sous vichy avec la préparation
avec le texte de loi de madame aubry
article par article
ce sont les mêmes mots ce sont les mêmes
phrases c'est sûr que quand vous leur
dites ça ne fait pas plaisir
et quand vous comparez à ce moment là le
texte de madame aubry avec un texte de
vichy forcément forêt socialiste et
actuellement désagréable c'est que vous
le faites inclus chien comme vous le
faites en plus à l'assemblée nationale
mais forcément il se lavait tout s'ils
sortent enfin c'est une réalité que je
dormais en me montrant simplement les
choses dont vous êtes tout ça pour dire
que vous êtes content les 35 heures
certes et on est dans une logique
terrible parce que nous on est on sait
pas bien faire ce qui concerne la
communication aubry a expliqué aux gens
que le tout de façon non c'est pas comme
unique elle a expliqué à l'ensemble de
la france que de toute façon on pouvait
dans la vie gagner autant doit peut-être
plus tout en travaillant moins oui c'est
beau ça qui est contre ça donc on essaie
un qui compte j'en connais pas et moi je
connais pas non plus de gens qui sont
susceptibles de réussir de gagner le
travail et en travaillant qu'à 35
millions - en travaillant moins jamais
vu quatre musiciens comme ça que vous
dites ces communicants non c'est facile
quand on pense aux communes il ya et
puis ça communique bien là oui c'est
comme les autres mais qui communique
bien vous trouvez que ça communique bien
c'est pas mal c'est quoi alors
maintenant on va vous connaître un petit
peu plus large est resté au plan
politique
maintenant on va faire une interview un
petit peu plus personnelle pour vous
connaître un petit peu mieux je crains
le pire
alors j'ai appelé ça entretien
d'embauché bougez pas
bon
[Musique]
voilà la lumière merci le jingle le
carton et comme la télé alors entretien
d'embauché donc répondez moi franchement
alors votre nom on le connaît muselier
prénom renault surnom alors sur nous et
vous appelez qu'un petit ou au musée
haut musée bas maison c'est joli petit
tout c'est vraiment un tout petit mon
travail quantité dans le monde s'appelle
comme ça
comment comment vous appelez-vous way
doudou en doute pendant vie din din din
din m'ont appelé titi je suis moins sûr
si on s'appelle comme ça oui non bon
alors muzeau vas-y petits signes
astrologiques tôt taureau ascendant
scorpion ça vous dit quelque chose
scorpion si sexuelle le sport pur non
parce que ça m'a toujours dit catherine
barma et score sinon bon jeu christine
lentz et aussi j'ai tous les douze sur
les scorpions moins bon alors votre père
pharmacien déporté à dachau
pourquoi nos distances résistance faits
de résistance très bien c'est lui qui a
créé la clinique que vous dirigez
aujourd'hui avec son associé qui est
monsieur joue comme si douala il a
décédé à quand vous aviez 29 ans voilà
un film c'est top
est-ce que c'est pas la mort prématurée
de votre père qui vous amène comme ça
toujours recherchés chirac match à un
autre papa non non non non je crois que
depuis que je suis tout petit je peux
pas m'empêcher d'ouvrir ma gueule quoi
ouais je dis ce que je crois moi un mec
de ce qui est convenu elle sonnait alors
votre maire bon pas vers ce mamère
j'adore voilà alors votre grand père et
le grand père c'est une star et lord
levene ma mère est une star la soeur de
la reine d'albanie a maintenant l'âge
est arrivé j arrivais alors halte est ce
que vous cherchez des jeux s'est éloigné
alors vous êtes le cousin germain de
l'eca premier roi d'albanie
qui est le fils de drogue ouais le roi
des aigles est le mari de géraldine la
reine d'albanie qui est la soeur de ma
mère ça sans cesse alors aujourd'hui le
les cas premier roi d'albanie vie en
afrique du sud
ouais il a un peu impliqué sur le trafic
d'armes non ouais ben ahui ben c'est
bien c'est bien enfin et olympique et
des envies d'armes ces objets dire oui
parce que de toute façon c'est un homme
qui vit en exil et il a eu six ou sept
tentatives d'assassinât contre lui bien
sûr donc il est évident que si nous
sommes contre les cas premier ici c'est
réjouissant père s'appelait zone roi des
règles bien tout seuls et l'époque il
devait donner des noms comme ça
le pouvoir en albanie votre temps
non c'est impossible bon alors quand
c'est un premier cousin nous
bon alors votre grand-père votre grand
père c'est l'amiral muselier donc il a
créé les forces françaises navale libre
n'est pas rien et alors quand on dit
qu'il a donnée la croix de lorraine à la
france ça veut dire quoi c'est lui qui a
eu l'idée du symbole c'est à dire mon
grand-père était sa mère était
marseillaise et son père étaient lorrain
a et donc et un en angleterre y diriger
avec de faim sous de gaulle
les forces aériennes des forces navales
aériennes fallait forces navales et
aériennes françaises libres
et pour faire la différence entre la
france libre et la france occupée il a
eu l'idée de la croix de lorraine qu'il
avait imprimé sur ces bateaux et sur ses
avions dans le blanc wef la différence
par rapport à la croix nazies
d'accord la france libre la france
occupée d'accord et après c'est devenu
le symbole de la france qui voit là
l'amiral muselier messieurs voilà voilà
alors déclamé 83 bonne foi soixante
seize kilos la france est bien laisser
dominique bien ça ouais les yeux fait
voir vous me voyez bien oui oui danger
j'ai dit c'est 10 mai suivant mes
interlocuteurs j'ai besoin les cadres la
religion chrétien fait tient alors les
vis maintenant vous fumez quoi fumer des
pétards non non thiery eelv à vous dire
oui celui-là ça communique mi temps mais
justement j'y suis je n'ai pas la tête
dans la farine je fume pas de pétard je
fume pas de cigarettes se fait plutôt du
sport je bois j'adore le vin et j'aime
la vie bon bah écoute est très bienvenue
quant à lui tu t'es vu quand t'as bu
alors est ce que vous êtes volage
je suis marié donc il est volage
à un petit peu avec michèle bernier le
démon de midi
donc je me suis marié en 81 5 85 mais je
la connaissais depuis pratiquement une
dizaine d'années avant bon bah donc ça
va pas tarder baptisé hier chérissez pas
chérie c'est bien d'avoir allumé la
lumière ses arches il te plait ben voilà
vous êtes prêté aux questions maintenant
visionner vous connais un petit peu
mieux
linda alors on sait que en ce moment on
en parle beaucoup du viagra et donc moi
je voudrais savoir si en tant que
médecin vous avez testé le viagra gelé
prescrits non c'est comme une colonie
répond jamais
je suis en politique j'ai gelé prescrits
j'ai voulu l'essayer mais ma femme me
l'interdît pourquoi la question pourquoi
après il faut maintenant la clim tout ça
alors c'est exactement ça par contre
d'avoir vos copains qui vous harcèlent
j'avais presque oui les femmes en
prennent
on me l'a jamais demandé donc beaucoup
du viagra féminin on commence à en
parler
basile et histoire de cette anglaise
mais c'est vrai que ça peut poser est
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
oui son fiancé et donc médecins une
jeune anglaise de 25 ans comme vous
comme moi j'avais pas faire
donc à tester le viagra wee masculin oui
et ça lui a permis d'avoir neuf orgasme
en deux heures non fausse les a comptés
avec avec le même ça fait c'était la
semaine d'art avec la maman et les a
comptés ces deux mêmes hommes avec le
même homme oui pris le temps d'écouter
ses gaston mais j'arrive à la france
alors même qu'il ait fait [ __ ]
mesdames messieurs maintenant
j'accueille quelqu'un qui depuis quinze
ans additionne les tubes et puis
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que tout ça
n'était que des bonnes chansons et ça
finit par faire un répertoire de qualité
j'accueille marc lavoine
comment ça va bien je venais michèle
bernier oui donc sa décennie perdue
pardon sur renaud muselier
bonjour india hardy et la la la la
france entière bonsoir j'ai dit bonsoir
bon alors marc lavoine thierry ardisson
ouais alors j'ai montré à la caméra 7e
doublement garçons septième album et il
s'appelle septième ciel à malin il ya
une chanson là dedans qu'on entend tout
seul la journée ça fait drôlement bien
cette chanson ouais c'est très bien
merci
vous connaissez cette chanson honoré
allait bien façon il va la chanter et
oui il est vachement bien cette chanson
ça tombe bien la tournesol caracol
machin c'est chef thémis est sympa mais
qui valent à chanter c'est pour ça qu'il
a dit là il va la santé des femmes que
j'ai pas arrêté au pot d'étain fait un
mort vivant
ces jeunes équipes ont de quoi vous
parlez il était caracol cagole aux
cadors c'est ce que c'est ma très bonne
une cagole non une cagole à marseille
c'est une [ __ ] chèque c'est la femme
du québec c'est là qu'elle jouera à
marseille ça l'a fait qu'à gauche
voilà bon alors septième ciel septième
album doo still dre composé six mois
c'est nouveau parce qu'elle avance
visitant les paroles sont vos albums
mais aussi qu'il était fort rare que
vous écriviez les musiques
oui ça oui parce qu'avant c'est fabrice
a voulu qu'ils accusaient la partie des
musiques il les faisait mieux que
j'imaginais pouvoir les faire moi même
et puis là bas tournesol la musique
c'est vous par exemple
pas mal pas mal oui je les co-composé
c'est un carillon acumen des chansons et
qui on est prêt à mener avec quelqu'un
juste un jeu sinon je vais à l'eau ça
valorise pas mon travail sinon regardez
quelqu'un qui fort dans la musique déjà
oui ça valorise le travail donc ça nous
engage à continuer alors maintenant on
va vous faire une petite
vous aurez un blind test à la fin de
l'émission merci thierry bouchard que
les tournesols ça nous fera plaisir
mais là on va faire une petite interview
story donc sur vous je ne bouge pas
[Musique]
voilà on est juste que tu colles et
voilà sérieux john et l'image tu mets
les traite en régie on va vous chasser
pareil c'est vrai que c'est moi la
musique c'est marrant mais on peut
essayer de faire des fondus enchaînés
c'est une trêve au niveau là on s'est
donné en 62 à longjumeau vous avez 37
ans vous avez passé votre enfance à
wissous ouais votre père il ya des
marseillais qui bavardent là bas ça
m'étonne pas que j'en suis sûr dès qu'il
ya tu mets trois marseillais ensemble
c'était jacques hopin dit que tu mets 3
mars effet garder il fait mater j'aurais
ils se marrent depuis le moi j'adore ces
gens là depuis le début rigole voilà ce
formidable est pas belle la vie
ouais voilà ça me manque ça alors votre
père marc lavoine oui votre père était
fan de jazz il voulait être saxophoniste
mais malheureusement il s'est retrouvé
au tri postal à vaugirard parce qu'il
était tendance les listes voilà il était
très à gauche
très à gauche très à gauche communistes
syndicalistes y vend des lumas dimanche
les écoles les affiches et où il connaît
les affiches et enfin politiquement
alors les lui seul a un peu gâché un
moment très banalement il a dit qu'il
avait un peu marre parce que tu es
militant et tout ça et il a dit mon
grand truc pour échapper aux propos
politisé syndicalistes de mon père qui
m'ont vite écoeuré voilà c'était partir
non écoeuré nom s'est pas départi tous
les week-ends à mobylette avec des
copains ils plantaient des tentes au
premier degré et il tourne et des
spectacles en plein air avec des super
vite voilà donc c'est vrai que quand
même c'est nous reste intéressant c'est
à dire que vous qu'elle est élevée donc
par un père de tout ultra gauche a pas
d'ultra gauche mais de très à gauche
tout moment le discours vous à non ces
produits on sait pas son discours lui
c'est simplement que moi j'aime pas trop
les chapelles
j'ai été élevé de mon père était à
témoin je suis croyant je trouve que
chacun doit trouver sa sa nature sa
vraie raison de vivre très rare il a
quand même un nom je crois pas non non
parce que dans tous les milieux fois que
les gens vont enfin ceux qui aiment
leurs enfants et ceux qui les leur
laisse le choix d'aider chose est sûre
c'est un pari bien dans votre histoire
c'est que finalement on fait toujours
souvent enfin on accomplit un petit peu
le destin que nous
pavan aurait voulu avoir on fait souvent
ce que alors vous votre père dont il est
fan de jazz saxophoniste il se retrouve
aux tripes résister à la logique a
évidemment ce n'était pas le rêve de sa
vie votre mère qui veut être pianiste
surtout dactylo et vous finalement vous
avez réussi un peu pour eux d'une
certaine façon oui mais quand même et
toujours une culpabilité là dessus un
peu ouais du de comme le communisme est
un échec il ya une sorte de d'un coup de
d'avoir du succès quand on vient d'un
milieu communiste il sait ce qu'on garde
un petit truc de culpabilité envers les
autres on n'a pas j'ai pas tellement
envie de
j'aime pas trop le brio tout ce qui se
voit tout ce qui se montre tout ce qui
est parce que je trouve que c'est une
agression un beau discours de tolérance
je passe sur après 120 jours il partait
pour de bon vous allez allions faire du
hard rock tout ça vous allez tout le
monde connaît l'histoire à vous est
coursier et ensuite à l'olympia il et
placer les ouvreurs et évidemment
c'était le supplice de tantale pour lui
parce qu'il voulait être tard puis tout
le temps il a mené les gens dans les
stars mais quand il passe devant
l'église
j'ai vu la lumière et donc
un jour patricia coquatrix donc vous
présente florence aboulker qui vous
présente son fils fabrice aboulker et
vous commencez à faire toutes ses
chansons alors je vais les faire écouter
parce que moi je trouve formidable tout
à l'heure ils sont pas toutes à je dis
simplement c'est un choix personnel
lieu relais voir brève elle le regarde
je dis la première et j'ai une maison
les arrange pour
jacques vélu la ruine
c'est les leurs on se met ça mais quand
à j'écris ce texte là j'avais 17 ans
c'est que le conte c'est dire elle fille
qui l'a jamais fait laisse toi aller ça
quand on a 17 ans on écrit un truc comme
ça quand on est ronde que cette série
géniale type de mondino avec catherine
ringer surtout catherine qui divise
je ne
ça c'est très vieux
[Musique]
j'aime bien aussi non mais alors
justement attendait mais quand il était
petit il était pas quand vous étiez
petits et grands noms mais d'accord va
lui rappeler museau je vous fais comment
des douves houdinois titi et voilà vous
appelez gras double c'est vrai ma plaie
gras double parce qu'il était gros
peut-être voilage bleu rouge on n'arrive
pas à le croire quand on le voit
maintenant je fais je travaille là
dessus alors les prénoms enfin les
surnoms ont changé jusqu'au dernier
combat udc ravalec qui m'a donné sur le
tournage du cantique de la racaille inca
immeubles et marcoux y mar couilles de
dire que le film s'y prêter vous étiez
le mari de claire nebout dans le même
mais c'étaient des échangistes qui
allait au cap d'agde il faut voir avoir
vu ce film ça existe c'était cela la
firme à coups de départ donc si toute
l'équipe est maintenant bien le chien
surnom vous aviez là c'est marco les
grandes feuilles
oui c'est fait je vois assez grande mais
elles n'ont pas poussé les feuilles
il a commencé par dire sérieusement vous
trouvé bon sérieusement je ne pense pas
la question et puis je m'en fous de ce
nom on retrouve tous vachement beau mais
je suis un vieux et en régie on me dit
aussi tout le monde vous trouve très
beau et il ya du beau linge en régie à
là il ya du fond ce2 et tu vois il ya de
l'allier de là à dieu lui là où il a
avec lui aux hommes et aux femmes alors
mais je n'aime pas tellement je préfère
doudou ezziddine jouer didier houi dit
mon physique je trouve plutôt dur
vous avez déclaré l'allemand physique je
trouve plutôt dur genre nazis couper au
couteau
parce que comme je suis très
impressionné quand je vais à la
télévision de sa peau dans une
institution parce que je les aime
beaucoup la télévision donc il ya des
endroit où j'ai tendance à me faire mais
sache plus beaux d'une certaine manière
si on parle de caen je suis décontracté
quand je suis en confiance ça je reste
parce que vous êtes bien là la chute
c'est ce que je fais ça mais lyon là sur
un plateau aussi les papiers arrivés il
est terrible 3 que la beauté c'est
donner c'est donner pleinement aux
choses et puis de faire corps avec la
nature va se faire à temps où elle est
où ma chanson moi on va se faire une
petite image rose
ça
lâchez vous donnez vous la main car et
c'est vous et restez vous tous la main à
la bouche et si quelqu'un la beauté sans
quelqu'un ça ne sert à rien alors
justement en 92 ou les là vous avez dit
ouais
en parlant du couple le côté on ne fait
plus qu'un mois ça me gonfle en 93 il a
déclaré jamais je ne dirai une femme on
est ensemble pour la vie car j'en sais
rien alors est-ce que sarah poniatowski
vous a fait changer d'avis ou est ce que
quand même vous pensez toujours ça non
je pense pas ça du tout vous avez changé
d'avis je suis amoureux de la femme que
j'aime donc si tu veux ça ça l'instant
de problème c'est pas michel qui s'en
plaindra pas par tous les cas c'est
quelqu'un qui l'a le démon de midi moi
non vous non pas pour le moment tout va
bien mais moi la sexualité c'est parce
que je préfère vous allez faire des vous
allez faire des malheureuses la mort de
l'amour quoi que vous préférez la
sexualité en dehors de l'amour ne
m'intéresse pas trop ce que je veux dire
donc oui j'ai jamais être chez quelqu'un
de peureux je suis pas du tout pourquoi
pas il préférait la mention sexualité
cas ça peut arriver ça peut m'arriver
on se demande et c'est parti communiquer
simplement est ce que ça ne fait pas un
choc vous fils de militants communistes
d'épouser la dernière descendante des
rois de pologne est ce que c'est pas
est ce qu'au niveau du jeu pas quand
vous avez amené chez vous puisque le
switch s'est bien passé j'ai viré le
écoute c'est rien c'est normal c'est
sexuel des mondes je vais répondre à la
première fois mais quand ils sont allés
chez les merengues loterie ce genre de
questions me déroute surtout venons de
vous parce que je sais que quelqu'un
extrêmement brillant mais je vous aime
beaucoup et c'est vrai que la question
je sais qu'il n'ya pas de vous c'est une
question qui traîne qui vous reprenez et
que vous me posez mais vous ne pensez
pas ça par exemple on sait pas qu un
maquis vers le mieux communiste aimé
quelqu'un c'est tout donc ça m'étonne
beaucoup encore à la chanson je ne vois
pas épouser monseigneur gaillot non plus
voilà par exemple il est passé de marché
ça veut dire simplement qu'on refuse
d'être surpris par la vie voilà dernière
question en marc lavoine ce mariage à
marrakech vous l'avez trouvé un peu mais
c'est trop médiatisé non c'est vrai et
thierry juteau peu médiatisé samassa va
pas at il à ce n'est pas idéal où c'est
comme cette question là c'est pas une
idée avoue c'est pas une idée à moi non
c'est à dire que si enfin veut pas non
plus ne pas assumer les choses c'est à
moi c'est moi qui les fais donc je suis
attaché de presse nous a dit quitter à
voir les journalistes sur le dos
otan-russie de les gérer quoi ici tout
lui c'est un enfer c'est que oui mais
met en revanche en revanche j'aime
beaucoup d'attachés de presse qui
travaillait pour moi à l'époque et je
lui en veux pas du tout je pense qu'il a
résonné d'une manière extrêmement
sincère
c'était à moi de ne penser que
finalement c'est vrai les attachés de
presse vit plus avec la presse qu'avec
les artistes d'une certaine manière et
j'aurais dû avoir une analyse c'est pas
très grave
comme quoi parfois faut savoir dire non
il faut savoir communiquer autour d'anne
dunant que l'onda
il m'est très sympa d'y perdre
merci de votre franchise
je suis heureux de voir comme ça sur un
plateau de télévision en france mais moi
je suis très heureux pour vous tirez
vous restez avec nous oui c'est vrai il
ya trois ans c'est ce qui arrive là qui
sont assez assez étonnante donges
accueille maintenant trois des auteurs
ou des autrices et nous dirons comment
il faut dire en tous les cas pas des
auteurs de la rentrée donc j'accueille
isabelle alonso karine bernfeld et
clotilde est allemand
[Musique]
à
bonjour jour isabelle alonso isabelle
alonso karine bernstein et clotide
escale voilà bon alors on va commencer
avec vous il appelle alors votre livre
voilà je le montre à la caméra
voilà ça s'appelle tous les hommes sont
égaux même les femmes séparées comme
petit nom fabien ça me paraît bien alors
vous n'est ce pas le premier en 95 avait
publié et encore je me retiens ensuite a
été remarquée puisque ça s'est plutôt
bien vendu
vous êtes parti aux grosses têtes
ensuite cette partie chez notre ami
laurent ok oui qui vous embrasse au
passage on se fait la bise pour lui on
s'est séparé sans se fâcher
ça donne ça c'est pas beau ça il est en
colère après la fée [ __ ] c'est tout
après moi non quand c'est extraordinaire
j'y la cpi doit définir hamish bond
alors donc chez laffont tous les hommes
sont égaux même les femmes alors de quoi
ça parle
parce que maintenant qu'on parlera d'une
pièce d'un match en plus et de quoi ça
parle
c'est un vibrant plaidoyer pour la
mixité alors pas seulement pour le
partage
entre les hommes et les femmes du monde
traditionnellement dévolue aux hommes
c'est dire la politique d'économie etc
mais aussi pour que les hommes viennent
dans le monde traditionnellement dévolue
aux femmes à savoir le soin aux petits
enfants et la culture et les travaux
ménagers la cire que vous vous êtes de
celles qui veulent que par exemple les
hommes donnent le biberon passe
l'aspirateur face les courses et tout ça
et ben oui c'est pas pour ça que je vois
c'est très bien ça j'adore 300 plateaux
là tu es d'accord toit très bien mise à
l'eau mais c'est normal mais un shérif
ne fait pas ménagé j'arrive j'arrive
mais j'arrive fait également les agents
les otages
c'est pas une fois de temps en temps
c'est la mixité dans tous les domaines
de la vie quoi mais est-ce que ça va
bien se passer bon écoutez je crois que
jeannot le c'est moi qu'on peut imposer
chez moi je suis d'accord mais est-ce
qu'on peut les imposer
en tout cas on peut au moins déjà en
parler parce que nous avons on impose
depuis maintenant je suis habituée
voilà lorsque c'est ce qu'elle va dire
de dire regardez même des mecs pas
compte dès qu'il est question du
féminisme et de vienne
remake pâques ont déjà dit non j'ai pas
les mecs pas qu'on oublie même des mecs
le show pourquoi en face à nancy mais
plus cultivés quand il part du féminisme
et canalsat
oui c'est vrai qu'à pas de culture il
n'y a pas de culture les mecs quand il
s'agit du féminisme ou des fermes en
général ils deviennent ils deviennent
analphabètes ils sortent leur moteur
j'espère pas forcément de revolver mais
c'est un signe vous savez le revolver
c'est le phallus donc fait le poids
je sens qu'on va passer une bonne soirée
tous ensemble au départ était dans la
vie politique c'est pas monsieur muesli
qui va être contre je sens qu'il va me
dire que j'ai raison
mais on peut aussi parler de parité dans
les cuisines les buanderies et les
crèches pour un 6ème si les mecs partage
pas ce genre de tâche là on n'y arrivera
jamais à la parité politique
donc voilà il faut parler de tout alors
vous vous êtes vous pensé non mais
sérieusement vous pensez que finalement
tout ce qu'on apprenne la féminisation
du monde actuel andy le monde se
féminise par exemple vous vous dites que
c'est un bluff médiatique que c'est pas
moi total
tout le monde sait féminise attention
les hommes sont angoissés parce que le
monde se féminise oui moi je dis aussi
des ovaires c'est comme l'oxygène ça
sera riffier avec l'altitude
c'est à dire que quand vous montez dans
les hiérarchies dans les
si vous aviez quand quand on monte dans
la hiérarchie il ya plus de femmes quoi
et cette féminisation du monde c'est pas
parce que les femmes sont devenues
visibles dans les médias par exemple sur
ce plateau jeune homme et une femme
est ce que vous êtes dans des positions
équivalente pas du tout et on comprend
la visibilité avec le pouvoir entend
conclure parce qu'il ya beaucoup à dire
mais là vous écrivez je me soucie guère
d'être l'égal d'un être acquis je ne
reconnais aucune supériorité
bien sûr en quatre jours il faut que les
femmes sont les égales des hommes et moi
qu'on ait aucune supériorité à l'homme
je vois pas pourquoi je vois là je moi
mon avis c'est qu'ils ont croqué de ça
aussi l'une des championnes
non il ya ça mais confortable du rockeur
blanc de la première aberration c'est de
voir que le numéro de sécu d'un homme
commence par un est celui d'une femme
par un de ces voiliers sa conscience de
notre aliénation qui a déjà agi
simplement une conscience de mon essai
non mais je ne n'y paraît les féministes
le plus important est celui qui nous a
apporté la contraception le droit à
l'avortement le droit de vote et c'est
la possibilité énorme que auquel nous
avons droit parce que nous sommes des
êtres humains à part entière et les
égales des hommes gèrent après les
histoires de couches et de course etc
je médite sur 100 milliards il ya un
moment où il y en a un des deux qui doit
le faire et je lui dis si on se met à
vred et donnant sur la nana oui eh ben
j'ai envie de dire aux médias bien j'ai
envie de dire aux filles mais attends
éduquez vos mecs ou choisissez un mec
bien avec ce faire
en effet
le problème c'était un peu quand tu as
fait l'effort pendant six mois il se
casse alors la belote
je voudrais pas je t'aime mon petit je
devais 6 mai lors dû rentrer le soir
après après le boulot tu vois tout le
monde avance et le matin à toi je te
raconte l'histoire c'est tous les jours
et puis là tu dit aux mecs bon écoute
génial tu peux relever le ch est un peu
saturé les dix derniers pressing c'est
moi les dix derniers supermarché c'est
moi les dix derniers bains du petit
c'est moi l'idée est le mec te regarde
et dit tu compte maintenant tu aimé ce
film déborde ça pour avoir l'appui tu
fais le boulot tu fermes ta gueule et tu
te tapes la deuxième fois la moi j' ai
je dit que c'est important aujourd'hui
que les nanas arrête je dire peut-être
bon moi ça y est c'est de la faute des
nanas non je dis pas ça je dis qu'il ya
ce qu'il ya un échange
il ya un échange qui doit être
obligatoire aujourd'hui géré le conflit
on peut pas le on peut pas le perpétrer
tout le temps tout le temps je pense que
c'est important que effectivement quand
on a envie de se battre on se bat pour
ce faire vous êtes où avec karim
bernfeld bonsoir donc
donc vous avez commencé en posant nue
dans des écoles de dessin oh là là ça y
est ça recommence
j'vois pas tomber non non non c'est
plutôt flatteur parce qu'on me l'a
jamais demandé
c'est vrai j'ai commencé par faire dix
ans de théâtre
ah oui elle ne mentionne pas de même que
je suis à la sorbonne mais ça ils ne
mentionnent pas si insensé qui semble
être une idée vous avez quand même
bosser pour le minitel rose aussi mais
ça par contre c'est pas gênant nous ça
nous choque pas non mais c'est vrai que
c'est vendeur de dire que j'ai posé nue
que je travaillais sur minitel rose plus
lavande alors si vous étiez d'accord
vous déshabiller ça serait encore plus
vendeur mais comme vous n'êtes pas
d'accord j'ai foi
c'est pas le sujet carton rouge à pépé
non procès d'intention d'accord c'est
l'attention
ils ont buté par ferdinand de théâtre
mais tout va bien on va bien pas trop la
santé publié chez lattès un livre que je
montre qui s'appelle apologie de la
passivité de quoi ça parle de quoi ça
parle c'est un journal intime à deux
voies s'il vous plaît les marseillais
excusez-moi karine c'est terrible mais
parce qu'il est pour la tolérance zéro
malades n'ont pas vexé comme un journal
intime à deux voix de deux personnages
une jeune fille stella qui a 16 ans un
jeune homme galade qui à 21 ans
l'idée de base de ce bouquin c'est il ya
quelques années j'ai failli faire des
gamins avec un type un peu un peu pas au
site avec moi on va dire et je me suis
imaginé ce que ses enfants seraient
devenus si on les avait faits voilà donc
c'est dans le paris des années 2000 et
quelques et c'était là aygalades son nom
écrivent tous les deux lors journal
intime insolence et sa femme si jacques
la haye pareil ça c'est moi moi moi
aussi je dois le résumer je dirais qu un
jeune adulte et héros tendance by tombe
amoureux d'une adolescente c'est pas mal
ça c'est à peu près ça va brasser
sait-on des étiquettes et moi j'ai dit
que n'ayant pas gagné à la maison
un jeune adulte et héros tendance beat
tombe amoureux d'une adolescente yen à
celle en 2001 renault vous y faire
formellement c'est de sedum important de
venir là c'est pas gagné la germination
mais bien quelque chose à gré et vous
quels sont ces vraiment les personnages
singuliers où vous vous trouvez que
c'est le reflet d'une société
aujourd'hui qui est complètement
déboussolée parce qu'on a l'impression
que c'est un peu c'est pas assez
régulier du tout puisque déjà pour
écrire ce livre j'ai pris dix ans de mon
propre journal intime donc message avait
bien compris mais en même temps c'est un
noël et trois claques et qui va très
très mal
bon je trouve pas y avoir mal non il ya
un côté d'espérer montoya beaucoup
d'humour yahia vous êtes très bonne
phrase car ils visitent je ne suis ni
terreau ni homo ni be je suis sexuelle
c'est vrai parce que j'aime bien courir
en fait c'est parce que je ne supporte
pas qu'on étiquettes les genres que
j'explique à catherine barma dans le car
qui me demande ce que veut dire courir
donc queer c'est le mouvement punk de
gender c'est à dire on casse les genres
ya plus d'hommes de femmes de paix
d'edwin tout ça on est tous pareils et
des êtres humains et des personnes
et avec chacun des moments où on peut
être un peu plus [ __ ] ou un peu plus
hétéro voilà qu'est ce qu'on pense
muselier pas 10 4 ça devient compliqué
quand même pas moi bien que là je je
comprends qu'on peut être passif un
moment dominant un autre désormais la
douleur mais pour autant y aller
pourquoi parfois on dit un mec qui se
fait prendre c'est un [ __ ] [ __ ] c'est une
insulte ok vous c'est à dire tant mieux
si c'est exactement vous dit m à
montesquieu prendre forcément un peu
moins mauvais que la moyenne et que
forcément puisque voilà vous dites oui
on a eu il ya quand même les mâles et
les femelles je veux bien coupé toute la
phrase mais enfin j'ai pas dit d'autres
trucs avant j'ai dû supporter dans la
vie sexuelle
ce qui veut dire c'est qu'elle pouvait
pour l'évolution mais moi je suis tirée
par les femmes
aujourd'hui renault allait aujourd'hui
peut-être peut-être peut-être à priori
ça devrait savoir déjà vous pouvez dès
qu'on s'en fout c'est que des noirs les
gens par leur pratique sexuelle n'a
strictement aucun vous voyez tous les
pratiques sexuelles ça à la fois c'est
d'ailleurs vos belles idées quoi c'est
que vous pourriez vous faire prendre
pénétrer être passif mais avec une femme
voilà ça serait déjà terminée pour le
mans / morts oui mais moi je voulais
continuer avec karine
il fut un temps où un député rpr qui
aurait eu des petits bracelets comme ça
ça aurait fait de l'achat manque rien
qu'est ce que tu veux c'est simple j'ai
fait sur la plage c'est est le chien l'a
choisie comme morale il sera réalisé
leurs pigeons
bon vous avez dit l'hétérosexualité est
la plus grande utopie de l'humanité donc
ça c'était là qu'il le dise et montage
c'est pas moi oui et elle avoue quand il
est pas loin de vous j'avais un reproche
à vous faire ça manque un peu de
distance par rapport aux vous voit que
c'est vrai c'est pas encore l'inter
n'est pas du tout anorexique have fun
dit oui bon ben voila mais vous manquez
derrière la non la mère restée là c'est
moi si je m'étais si je m'étais pas
soigné et quoi c'est vraiment ce à quoi
ma mère elle n'a rien d'une anorexique
bon alors il ya une phrase que j'ai re
voir relever c'est l'inconvénient avec
les mecs ça ça va être un beau sujet de
discussion pour nous ce soir de sa vie
énorme
l'inconvénient avec les mecs c'est que
dès que tu j'ai mis un peu il pense que
tu as eu un orgasme
et oui c'est vrai vous croyez qu'il sans
doute pas les mecs quand vous faites
semblant n'ont pas attendu pour qu'ils
vous nous prenez ouais voilà je suis moi
ce n'est pas la même a justement vu la
moyenne qui m'a filé un grand calme et
dans le dialogue c'est justement c'était
l'adx n'a aucun intérêt stimuler parce
qu'en plus on fait croire aux mecs que
ça nous plaît alors qu'en fait c'est
mieux donc elle dirait inverse elle dit
franchement il vaut mieux se taire comme
ça il va se rendre compte qu'ils après
il ya aussi sa jane que je me termine le
mec ça elles sont bien le petit train
vide juteuse maintenant la non le plus
tard parce que les petites fautes mais
son regard dans l'hétérosexualité l'acte
sexuel se termine avec les accumulations
donc l'homme
si la fille elle a pas eu son compte
qu'est ce qu'elle fait bon bah c'était
là c'est ce qu'elle fait elle dit bon ça
jane que je termine mon mal mais qui le
prend mal quoi l'agencé quoi marc
lavoine bosser plus ample de
communication que de sexualité oui s'il
estimait que gentil veut dire mais je
vais t'aider
bien sûr mais pour les trouver vous
imaginez moi je suis tellement bien
comme ça mais oui j'en suis là mais
c'est vrai en plus eu tellement pas
comme ça que je comprends pas qu'ils
aient des mecs qui laisse les filles se
terminer tout seul c'est vrai je jure
bon petit dans ma place est à vous water
pic
quand je demande à quoi ça servait ouais
voilà le type d escale alors vous bon
alors j'ai pas j'ai pas dire de bêtises
enfance au maroc les personnes ici quels
financements vous n'ont personne à la
sauce je suis leurs vacances mais
mohamed 6 à votre mariage n'empêche non
c'est pas bon trois paramètres c'est
bien puis tout d'un coup quand on habite
une cité c'est moi je suis tu enlèves
les six élus personnes en france au
maroc grotowski enfin ça m'impressionne
beaucoup des quais un mec de théâtre
canon polonais moi je suis scotché là et
puis trois livres et le dernier cerbère
jouit chez calmann lévy alors je vous
faire le même voilà ça parle de quoi moi
je le sais mais je vous laisse le
raconter ça parle du désir d'un
vieillard qui est satisfait par une
jeune femme voilà c'est pour ça qu'ils
s'appellent herbert jouit le vieux
s'appelle herbert jones 75 70 75
et avant de mourir il aimerait connaître
quand même la jouissance une dernière
fois
parce que les vieillards finalement leur
univers très triste si énormément un
moment donné ils se demandent s'ils vont
arriver à marcher s'ils vont arriver à
boire à manger puis à la jouissance et
la jouissance dans ce cas là c'est une
élévation c'est la lumière c'est pas
sale c'est pas c'est pas pornographique
c'est la jouissance un point c'est tout
et ce vieillard vers envie de jouir et
comme c'est un roman une jeune fille qui
passe par là qu'elle ait pas de sens
elle est entre elles et en même temps
aider quand elle l'embrassé
quand elle rencontre jeudi wendy
s'appelle herbert il a les yeux
globuleux un sourire plutôt gentil
ce qui est bien c'est que derrière
propres bien sûr il a un peu voûté
tremble sur ses jambes
bae a 75 ans mais qu'en même temps il
alors herbert ce qui est rigolo c'est
que je suis les cetc dans une société
comme la nôtre c'est vrai qu'on occulte
beaucoup la vieillesse un moment donné
hop au placard et ce qui m'est arrivé
m'est arrivé dans ma vie d'aller dans
des maisons de retraite et de voir ses
vieux complètement livrés à eux mêmes
attachez parce que ils avaient un désir
il avait un fantasme et puis on l'est on
leur remettait leurs culottes et puis
voilà et on leur donner des calmants et
chose de très très pathétique et
nettoyer mois attend dé moi j'ai
cinquante quand j'entends ce genre de
truc je commence à flipper et moi non
mais attends là quand j'entends ça et
bien j'ai repéré des vieux qui me
regardait une drôle de façon
passons beaucoup de temps dans cette
maison de retraite je me suis j'ai
commencé à fantasmer et je me suis dit
herbert doit connaître la jouissance
avant d'aller en maison de retraite
voilà mais vous vous étiez déjà un peu
prédestiné avec leur ce genre de bouquin
parce qu'ils se refusent à les coucher
avec le croque mort qui est venu
chercher votre grand-mère nom dans les
livres dans l'allée sinon vrai nom anne
à non parce que je me disais je me
demandais si c'était au tour des gars ça
que vous raconter tellement bien et les
détails que je ne peux pas donner
pourquoi parce qu'on est sur france 2
est une chaîne de service public
je peux pas le dire mais quels sont les
détails sur sa main mais c'est vrai que
quand acheter c'est vrai que le temps
consacré à son génie sont tous là non
mais c'est très bien mais c'est alors si
ces pauvres hères berne avant qu'il peut
pas assumer deux choses à la fois à
tantôt iband tantôt il veut me faire
jouer et elle est très attachée à le
faire jouir
ouais ouais hier dont on se demande est
ce que c'est un ange du ciel
l'envoyé du ciel qui est là pour donner
un peu de bonheur à ce pot werber ou
est-ce qu'au contraire si névropathe
gérontophile oui je prendrai plus que
maintenant
nous devons passer sa main anges du ciel
qui fait ça par compassion peut-être
après que dans sa problématique
elle préfère trouver refuge auprès d'un
vieillard avait plus subir le regard de
la société comme finalement ce vieillard
et order de la société donc il peut y
avoir c'est samuel s'amusent comme des
enfants ils se cachent de la société ils
font leurs petites choses avec légèreté
parce qu'on dit que c'est sa loupe sais
c'est pas honnêtement il ya des trucs
sont pas très ragoûtant dont quinze
jours des poils qui traînent dans les
baignoires un peu de ses souvenirs et
violent parfois la vue basse là d'accord
vous avez une vraie vous avez une vraie
compassion pour les lyonnais
je vais garder votre calme et autres on
sait jamais bonjour merci les filles
donc je rappelle or les titres des
livres
isabelle alonso tous les hommes sont
égaux même les femmes voilà c'est chez
qui je vois pas là robert laffont très
bien ensuite qu'à berne fait d' apologie
de la facilité c'est chez qui j'ai un
taux de la teste et vous donc herbert
jouissez chez calmann lévy et vous
appelez kotil escale
merci beaucoup les filles on l'applaudît
excellent vincent lalala s'est inquiété
un jeu des doulas ouhlala vives à rive
et alors elle sait les vieux voilà bah
cessation de leur part secrète le freine
dans les avions choisi bon alors
j'accueille maintenant mesdames
messieurs quelqu'un qui le 17 octobre
avec son frère ivan va partir pour la
transat jacques vabre donc sur son
trimaran foncia qui s'appelait primagaz
avant vous l'avez tous reconnu bien sûr
c'est non non non
[Applaudissements]
ben gourion voilà alors la chance pour
nous de là c'est la totale
moi je suis bientôt le temps d'installer
le bateau alors oui tout de suite avec
moi c'est aller j'en profite de cadre au
zoo est parti parce que l'accord pendant
que j'étais là je me suis tenu à carreau
alonso est bon alors lobognon donc la
transat jacques vabre du havre à
cartagena
oui alors c'est quoi le circuit il a dit
nous la combattions connais pas bien la
géographie mais alors on parle d'eux
du havre oui incroyable ce que la wii et
ensuite on va donc on va virer la
barbade
ouais on remonte tout les antilles
jusqu'à saint barthélémy au nicaragua
vous prenez la coke si vous la prenez à
saint barthélemy oui enfin fo colombie
et nous livre la religion c'est le
retour
c'est en retour qu'ils prennent la coque
à cartagena et ensuite on va sur
carthagène à carthagène voilà c'est
parce que les mines traque en fait
partie et vont en direct et nous en fait
on a un petit peu plus rapide nous font
faire des petits zigouigouis un petit
peu pas vous partez le lendemain vous en
plus ce n'est pas le lendemain matin au
lendemain alors déjà donc en 97 vous
avez gagné cette course 1 et qui vend
même avec le vent et cette année c'est
yvan qu'est skipper pourquoi parce que
c'est son partenaire foncia et voilà
c'est du sérieux risques et maintenant
c'est lui qui va reprendre le bateau
jusqu'à la prochaine route du rhum que
vous allez faire vos moi je suis en
train de construire un catamaran 38e et
le fameux truc le gros projet là voilà
alors vous avez déclaré laurent bourgnon
pour moi à faire de la télé c'est aussi
contraignant que brosse et la coque de
son bateau il faut le faire je le fais
mais quand on me demande pas en plus de
sourires et là vous souriez là vous
seriez d'accord et c'est vrai qu'on
avait avant tout notre passion c'est
naviguer c'est avec un plaisir sur l'eau
et mais bon cela dit on change un petit
peu notre fusil d'épaulé parce qu'on
rencontre des gens formidables ou non
mais vous avez dit vous savez que la
première fois que j'étais au théâtre
pour les voir michel
ouais c'est bien très difficile et je
devais avant c'était pas le démon de
midi
c'est bien demander la première fois que
l'ofj juste après j'ai vu michel
complètement vrai je suis certain que
vous allez le voir en salle des mandats
on est vraiment en sonar on se marre du
début à la fin
mais l'ex prix que j'ai vu tout à
l'heure m'a plu ou alors moi je vous
connaissais pas très bien vu et donc
j'ai appris beaucoup
j'ai lu votre vie et c'est vrai après
tout le monde doit la caunette j'imagine
c'est une star énorme mais quand vos
parents étaient boulangers dans le jura
suisse à la chaux de fonds
wen jusque là rien de voilà et puis
alors quand quand même que j'ai toujours
les frontières
quand vous avez quatre ans vos parents
lisent le vagabond des mers du sud de 4
ans - tessier et là ils vendent la
boulangerie ça c'est énorme
ils vendent la boulangerie il achète un
voilier de 12 mètres
le père bourny ont fait un stage de
trois semaines aux glénan donc on veut
pas dire que c'est vraiment ça
et qu'est-ce qui fait vous il traverse
l'atlantique c'est à dire c'est vrai un
tout à fait mais il était passionné en
fait au départ par laventure les voyages
les rencontres
ouais et connaissez absolument rien en
bateau et voilà on de stage de quinze
jours ils ont les ont mis les voiles
direct on est partis en famille c'est
incroyable comme ses amis taurins
ouais alors votre maire après se
retrouve enceinte de votre frère yvan là
il rentre à pornic visage est à café
mais quand il vend à 9 ans et vous 13
ans un tour du monde à la voile
voilà en six mois en fait l'objectif au
départ c'était de voyager donc
finalement quand on arrive en polynésie
le moyen plus court pour rentrer c'est
de faire le tour et puis voilà quoi donc
on s'est baladé procès des parents
incroyable ça a aidé ou dont vous très
jeune quoi dès l'âge de 13 ans ce métier
équipiers quoi vous tenez votre place
sur le bateau en fait c'est à dire votre
père en soit les caveaux musées obligés
mais alors là vous avez passé sept mois
aux marquises d'aller à l'école en
planche à voile a eu une enfance
difficile
voilà et laurent 86 là je raconte un peu
mais c'est quand même encore des gens
qui vous connaissent pas en 86 des vingt
ans et là vous faites l'atlantique en
hobie cat
voyons donc il faut savoir c'est un tout
petit bateau à lobby quadrillage pc on a
20 ans on est plein d'énergie et c'est
vrai qu'on a envie de se faire plaisir
quand on est en recherche de la
recherche de sensations et c'est vrai
que là on s'était fait 22 jours de piste
noire 132 remontantes way et c'était un
plaisir quoi c'était c'est les petits
engins des engins de plage à l'origine
willoughby 4 sait rien et dans les
vagues
enfin c'était fascinant quand c'est fait
vraiment plaisir quand vous arrivez et
de l'autre côté il y avait la route du
rhum qui arrive et tout le monde est
sceptique tout le monde j'attends c'est
pas possible qu'ils aient traversé
l'atlantique en hobie cat et
heureusement il est philippe poupon qui
venait de gagner la route du rhum est
qui
difficile vous allez croiser et non pas
moi pas du tout mais il faut être en
touche menu pour le faire euh ah oui non
mais s'est défendu la pression les
bureaux toute la journée
alors pour vouloir remonter leurs prg la
mer c'est fantastique c'est beau c'est
merveilleux mais c'est vraiment
dangereux en plus on va voir la tuta de
clément un petit document qu il faut se
connaître un petit peu le le métier
après voilà c'est marc held assez tendu
oui sourit à 7 puis ça ne fait pas
marrer disons que la solitude c'est pas
on a des courses en solitaire mais ce
n'est pas l'objectif d'être seul sur un
bateau s'arrête aux débiles des taux
vivement les courses en double mixte
comme ça sera beaucoup plus sympa
tellement de femmes dans notre métier
qui est bon par la florence arthaud ça
donne pas envie de partir en mixte avec
elle alors vous êtes un maniaque 1 c'est
bien connu
vous êtes vous êtes un mort un dangereux
névropathe c'est beaucoup beaucoup de
ballons lui à souffrir de vous jeter un
de signaler ici
non vous vous êtes un malade du
rationnement c'est à dire que vous déjà
quand vous aviez fait votre traversée la
robic à des 120 bouteilles d'eau dans
les flotteurs si vous êtes un maniaque
du rangement
par exemple vous arracher les étiquettes
de vaud de vos vêtements
il coupe le et coupant en deux le manche
de sa brosse à dents pour ça pèse moins
lourd parallèle il padre chaud ils
jettent à l'eau le tout ce qui pèse du
poids quoi c'est ça mais en fait l'objet
qu'ils ne s'inquiètent pas de femmes en
fait que l'on sache c'est pas le
l'objectif c'est véritablement de
préparer le mieux possible le bateau
donc on fait attention à chaque petit
détail
justement pour qu'une fois parti il n'y
a pas de pas de problème on le mange de
la brosse à dents c'est beaucoup quand
même assuré un petit catamaran de sport
en fait le moindre kilo est important on
essaie de
d'être attentif et alors pour dormir
donc comme il n'ya pas de femmes pour
pour dormir pour vous pratiquer l'auto
hypnose c'est comment quel rapport
[Rires]
donc si je comprends bien après l'amour
tu te mets sur le côté tu te retournes
disons que ça aide à s'endormir de faire
l'amour oui non balles au thorax
éléments bien compliqué pour expliquer
des en fait la gestion du sommeil on
essaie de de réduire les cycles de
sommeil dormira sur commande à des
moments donnés quand la météo nous le
permet ce qui fait que ben on est on est
le plus possible à la disposition du
bateau pour faire marcher le bateau
alors merci en tous les cas moi je vous
connais mieux j'espère que nos amis
téléspectateurs aussi
alors maintenant on va regarder un petit
un petit sujet filmé où on voit quand
même que c'est pas drôle tous les jours
ce truc-là magnéto serge
[Musique]
ah bon
ma
chez nous
deblé
[Musique]
chaud
quand vous êtes candidat lors du sujet
et on a vu au début quand même vous
n'êtes pas l'air d'être c'est qu'en
basse expliquez-nous la situation mais
ce qui se passe c'est que c'est les
machines très stressant donc il ya des
moments quand etc prennent de la
compétition c'est qu'il faut mener les
machines au maximum de leurs limites
sans les dépasser donc il ya énormément
de de temps finalement où on est très
stressé quoi parce qu'on est on est
vraiment au maximum de la vitesse et la
machine est soumise à rude épreuve et
finalement nous on est là on se demande
si on va trop vite s'il veut pas casser
du matériel parce qu'une fois le
matériel cassé c'est fini ça va convient
par exemple ces bateaux là ce sont les
bateaux qui vont finalement le plus
rapidement le ce sont les bateaux les
plus rapides à la voile la caméra passe
km heure 49 qui fait à peu près 80 km
heure ce qui est rien entendu en vitesse
pure mais sur l'eau à la voile c'est
très rapide c'est dangereux
alors maintenant on va faire une petite
interview et c'est normal pour un marin
une petite interview on ne bouge pas bon
alors une interview à peine d'abord le
plus le moine aussi ce que vous préférez
dans le bateau dans le bateau dans la
machine enlevé de faire du bateau je
préférais les surfs à 25 noeuds sous
pleine lune ça c'est fabuleux mais on
voit là les bacs scintiller sans lui
c'est vrai c'est fantastique c'est ce
que vous détestez dans le bateau ce que
je déteste dans le bateau c'est
justement quand quand on casse du
matériel tracy terrible ça parce qu'on
la prépare on se prépare toute l'année
avec toute une équipe et où et quand on
casse du matériel c'est un échec quoi
c'est très dur c'est le koïfhus
interrompu ce f
par exemple le plus grand nombre on sait
que ça existe
avant que la pilule août et a pas connu
ça avant arnaud avant que la pilule
avait le coïtus interruptus tu que vous
connaissez vous sauter du train et la
méthode ogino il est alors le plus grand
le plus grand lui connaît le plus grand
moment de votre vie mais en tout cas des
grands moments de bonheur sur le hobie
cat c'était quand on va traverser
l'atlantique à 20 m et c'est vrai que
des valets ces vagues à pleine pleine
vitesse c'était absolument numérique
quoi c'était au niveau d'adrénaline j'ai
rarement connu aussi fort et le pire
moment ça a été par exemple à la
rencontre avec un cargo en plein centre
de plein face avec un cabaret la nuit
comme ça vous dormez puis d'un seul coup
en plus j'étais sur le pont et les
cargos maintenant sont tellement long
que finalement on n'entend pas dire que
quand on est à l'étrave du bateau on
n'entend pas le moteur et donc j'ai
longé l'ensemble du cargo et donc c'est
un cargo qui était vide et à la sortie
donc j'ai vu les hélices qui sortait à
moitié de l'eau et heureusement le mât
en fait m'a empêché de passer sous la
voûte du cargo à l'arrière est passé
dans les hélices ah oui c'était une
belle
c'est le pire moment ça vous dit
d'ailleurs une phrase de vous quand on
peut tous inspiré parfois on croit être
à bout et on arrive à trouver une
énergie incroyable
c'est ce qui m'intéresse en solo dans la
course en solitaire d'ailleurs c'est pas
du tout fait d'être seul ce qui est
plutôt hostile à dépasser mais c'est
justement d'aller chercher des forces
intérieures que wanda chacun entre nous
mais quand elle utilisera donc sommes
pas dans la vie de tous les jours parce
qu'on n'a pas besoin en fait ce qui vous
plaît le plus dans la vie c'est quoi les
gens nous y rencontre
vibrez de ce qui faisait le mort 1 tout
ce qui est justement le contraire
l'hypocrisie le chercher du pognon
auprès des sponsors du recel en cause du
genre de voilà maintenant que c'est pas
facile c'est vrai que c'est pas facile
c'est la communion des sports mécaniques
en fait c'est du sport coûteux et pour
s'exprimer on a besoin de matériel et
donc de partenaires pour voilà alors que
michel est là que son talent pour pour
pouvoir s'exprimer vous aime beaucoup
mais on s'aime bien que ces formes là
vous êtes plus sexy on vous laurent
bourgnon joker vous savez bien saisir
c'est pas la chance vous avez de moins
sexy alors je dire quand on fait des
métiers comme ça des choses aussi
passionnante avec autant de coeur on ne
peut être que quatre en argent peut
admirer ces gens sont obligatoirement
peuvent rien avoir de mots chambon oh la
la
il n'y a pas une classe bac et l'annoncé
da sa magie père et moi j'aurais peur
moi aussi pour des coups de téléphone
surtout on a un téléphone satellite
après c'est qu'on a le fax il m'a l'air
un peu moins drôle maintenant si on peut
avoir sa femme au téléphone tous les
soirs qu'est ce que tu fais ce que je
fais au mieux de l'atlantique
t'es sûr tu es sûr que tu es sage
maintenant bien sûr je suis seul et nous
on est obligé de se faire la cuisine le
ménage c'est aux attentes id à rallonge
où on en parlait donc mademoiselle
alonso j'avais quelqu'un est prêt tout
car bon maintenant alors merci on va
rallumer la lumière dans sert mon cher
serge khalfon très bien et j'accueille
quelqu'un que j'adore parce que là ça
fait à peu près douze fois que je la
reçois dans mes émissions ça dort au
début pas trop pire maintenant ça va
beaucoup mieux elle s'appelle villon
résout ni au bon soir renaud muselier a
chanté le rpr qui monte
ah ouais j'ai pas dis que je vais
remonter j'ai mes repères qui monta à
les couples se forment laurent blanc n'y
aura pas sa femme michelle mais revient
trop machel épouse michelle voilà voilà
marc lavoine vous connaissez lindau midi
voilà qu'on est tous là un ça va
cette violence au bruit très content
alors lille où je vous accueille pour
une comédie musicale aux folies bergère
qui s'appelle sept filles et 7 garçons
alors l'histoire je la raconte et vous
me voir parce que les gens pensent que
c'est une énorme part tout ce qui se
passe aux folies bergère
c'est pas le cas là c'est pas le cas non
non non non c'est une histoire qui est
connu d'ailleurs si elle était élue à un
film un film hollywoodien donc ses sept
frères qui vivent sans femmes 1
et puis à l'aîné qui va la ville pour en
chercher une dire amen emilie qui doit
éduquer ses frères un petit peu rustre
un petit peu lourdaud qui confondent un
peu les femmes avec les vaches laitières
faut le dire avec des bonniches et puis
alors je m'entraîne rose ou the party
et puis emilie ne veut pas être victime
de son destin donc elle essaye de les
deux les à leur apprendre à avoir un
regard un peu plus tendres sur elle à
l'afp parce que c'est ça toujours de la
douceur on obtient tôt avec ça ils
devraient en prendre de la graine
bon alors ce que je propose là c'est
qu'on envoie le magnéto non surement
voyez le magnet au magnéto serge
m
toujours bien situe seulement comment
s'orienter jours
[Musique]
adolescent
non à nos pieds
elle
non jamais menti veulent éclair unis par
les liens sacrés du mariage
[Musique]
et
et alors vous dites la comédie musicale
enchante parce que les sentiments sont
tellement fort qu'on peut plus parler
c'est une bonne définition de comédies
musicales j'avoue oui je tourne pas ce
qu'il faut mais ça c'est peut-être on
définit quand nous on doit le faire
parce que c'est vrai qu'on commence par
de la comédie on est dans quelque chose
qui est beaucoup plus proche de nous et
tout d'un coup il faut se lancer ou en
ré milieu d'une phrase à chanter à
pleine voix qu'alors il faut bien
trouver pourquoi
et bien parce que c'est beaucoup plus à
chaque fois c'est que si on est
tellement elles ont peu plus que chant
que chanter la cimade très bonne
définition d'un comédie musicale sur les
sentiments sont tellement fort qu'on les
gens là on les chante
c'est vrai je vais jamais moi j'aime
bien cette présentation du féminisme
comme ça ah oui c'est ça je m'étonne pas
été repéré grâce à bond alors lis on va
faire une interview maintenant on va
baisser la lumière à ailleurs on ne
mange pas
[Musique]
voilà voilà c'est ma joie il ya le
sampler aussi tiens je vais vous mettre
pas une mauvaise nuit à la croisière
s'amuse c'est agréable
la chanson tout est rose et sa j'adore
alors je suis un bon score mon prof de
gym branchez mon sport il mais ça sinon
à quoi bon alors lihau vous allez
diviser déclaré c'est bizarre j'ai
toujours été une femme seule j'étais
accompagné finalement très peu de temps
et j'ai eu mes enfants avec des hommes
différents
ma célébrité finalement est un énorme
problème dans ma vie sentimentale est ce
que vous pensez vraiment que si vous
n'aviez et étudier pas été lui aussi
vous étiez resté wanda est ce que vous
auriez moins de problèmes avec les
hommes oui pourquoi parce que c'est très
difficile de se retrouver à un moment
donné comme étant monsieur lio et moi je
n'ai entendu ça des gens qui venaient
qui présentait mais mes hommes comme
monsieur lio est en fait moi je trouvais
c'était ridicule de la part des autres
mais eux petit à petit trouvé ridicule
de ma part des trios mais qui est
dommage parce que je l'étais avant je
pouvais pas arrêter tout d'un coup
c'était maintenant c'est comme une
seconde nature lio et ça a posé des
problèmes il ça pose des problèmes
je mets des problèmes de gagner plus que
son âme bon alors c'est vrai alors donc
voila moi j'ai fait le compte quand même
là lieu du juge dira d'abord c'est
marrant on trouve normal par contre de
dire là dans ma chère madame tout le
monde s'en fout bush a ring on s'est
suffisamment chamailler sur des plateaux
pour que je puisse vous faire un
compliment sincère je vous trouve très
belle en ce moment là là présentement
des âmes ainsi très joli vous êtes vous
une belle robe vous et des belles nappes
et j'adore les brunes et vous avez du
rouge à lèvres un peu rouge ça ça me
plaît ça perd béatrice te le dise tu
pouvais mettre le même genre de rouge à
lèvres que liu ça me ferait plaisir
voilà bon allez maintenant on fait
vraiment
les du sud c'est normal une portugaise
et un ça le fait un renouveau avec
ortega show là elle est vraiment parfait
le réseau il est chaud je te dis pas non
et titi titi est aussi bon alors j'ai
compté les sommes avancées pas encore
gloria lasso mais quand même c'est sur
la route 1 c'est-à-dire il ya eu d'abord
votre premier duval il faut bien prendre
le parolier qu'on adore tous ben voilà
faisait 13 ans et demi oui ensuite il ya
eu estévenens notre ami est et ben qui
vous avez qui vous est venue bien oui
ensuite j'ai eu patrick alexis avec qui
vous a eu deux enfants igor et général
d'à comptant les déjà 1 2 3 oui non
attendez
non maintenant 1 2 3 4
zad le dernier en date celui avec qui
vous avez des jumelles voient là un
grand coup photo c'est vrai beaucoup
mais non ah bon mais je suis vieux je
vois les enfants à chaque fois à
l'espagne 5 en format non c'est
d'ailleurs liés aux affaires de famille
c'est vrai lio c'est je le sais moi je
vous ai vu à l'été nubia sur les
plateaux il ya aux bains douches
alors vous avez déclaré mon ami hugo
pratt mais elle est pourtant conseillé
de ne pas tuer le désirent dans ce
milieu avides de chair fraîche
personne ne veut d'une fille avec cinq
gosses aux basques
vous pensez que ça vous handicape
aujourd'hui tous ces enfants mois 6 mois
sam handicap ainsi j'ai un micro ce pas
là moi ça me handicape pas le contraire
dans ma vie de femme sait quelque chose
de génial mais ça ça handicape dans mon
travail mais oui bien sûr sam handicap
dans mon travail parce que c'est pas de
trouver des gens en général les femmes
veulent bien de travailler avec moi mais
derrière une femme réalisatrice il ya
toujours un homme producteurs et le
producteur lui n'a pas envie d'une
artiste à problèmes entre guillemets
c'est à dire quelqu'un qui pourrait
éventuellement lui refusé de lui donner
la 200e heures supplémentaires gratos
puisque c'est maintenant ce qu'on vous
demande moi depuis que j'ai commencé à
tourner mes cachets ont été divisés par
3 voire 4 toujours soi disant pour des
problèmes de cinéma français qui ne
marche pas mais j'ai toujours vu les
producteurs avec la même bmw et les
mêmes costumes chez roule donc
donc vous voulez je trouve que c'est à
comme un nouvel ex esclavagisme parce
que comme on manque de boulot c'est
difficile pour tout le monde donc on
commence à dire aux techniciens faut
diviser vos prix et puis si c'est pas
vous qui le web
voilà et donc ça c'est effectivement et
donc qu'il ya autre chose qui joue c'est
quand tout d'un coup des producteurs ont
le choix entre lio est une autre et une
autre brune pas trop grosse
ils vont prendre peut-être l'autre brune
joli mais qui a pas cinq enfants et moi
je vais être éliminés sur ce critère
immédiatement oui mais c'est la vérité
je n'ai pas vraiment qu'alonso est pas
là dites moi où est mon petit gars pour
une fille qui a eu cinq enfants que des
vaches combien pour une fille kidnappée
je serai en france je commence à cinq
enfants ça serait normal pour une
séquelle 50 en revanche combien presque
40 ans est vrai comme en fait je baise
c'est des petits veaux les enfants n'ont
pas dit non non non non michel me
connaissez je vais
on enregistre alors vous vous disiez
donc là vous avez des problèmes avec
votre juges actuels et pourtant vous
disiez je crois que j'ai trouvé ce que
je cherchais je suis une butineuse il me
faut un vrai appel pour m'arrêter
avec lui il ya une vraie osmose comment
ça se fait que ce soit terminé aussi mal
après cette vraie osmose ah mais ça je
me fais toujours la question que je
continue à me poser qui me posez c'est
que des sacrés problèmes
je ne sais pas non c'est pas parce qu'un
jour cette question quand ça se termine
mais c'est pas un an vous aviez l'air
d'être tellement d'avoir enfin trouvé
mais je suis très amoureuse de lui
toujours oui mais je ne veux plus jamais
vivre avec lui avons différents vous
allez vous revoir quand même n'en a pas
le droit
bon vous êtes un peu disputées bon pas
là pour dire ça donc lui il a quand même
pris deux mois ferme
oui oui oui mais moi j'ai pris un et
cassé ouais ouais d'accord vous ne vous
êtes pas porter visite j'ai pas porté
plainte par vengeance je vais quand même
un peu porter plainte si l'on n'a pas
pris deux mois ferme et j'ai sorti test
parce que quand on porte plainte c'est
qu'on n'a pas d'autre solution quand on
essaie de régler des problèmes comme on
peut avec ses moyens mais qu'à un moment
donné on va d'échec en échec et de
violent sans violence eh bien on s'en
refaire à la justice c'est pas que je
trouve ça formidable mais c'est que je
n'avais pas d'autre solution
la justice représente le père c'est une
autorité à laquelle on s'en remet quand
on reconnaît notre échec notre échec à
nous de résoudre le problème voilà vieux
vous avez dit que vous jugiez la
sanction un peu sévère là les six mois à
faire les six mois de prison n'ont
jamais dit ça je ne je ne suis pas a
priori pour la prison parce que je
trouve que c'était pas là qu'on résout
les problèmes mais
mais les deux mois ferme n'était qu'une
partie de la sentence
et moi j'avais besoin de protection et
gelé obtenus et la justice a fait des
grands pas pour les femmes battues et
fallait qu'elle les fasse parce qu'on
est vraiment seul dans ces cas là et
surtout vous êtes toujours coupable mois
la plupart des hommes qui m'ont parlé
depuis n'ont pas du tout le sentiment de
s'adresser à une victime mais c'est
comme les femmes victimes d'un violent
c'est que je les bien cherché comme en
plus le monde sait que c'est un sale
caractère on se dit que vraiment j'ai dû
torturé ce pauvre homme c'est quand même
moi qui avait le nez cassé et le une
entorse cervicale et quatre vertèbres
déplacées qu'on a dû remettre le les
folies bergères et que ça a été terrible
et que je m'en remets toujours pas moi
en tout cas sûr ça ne se voit pas et sur
scène ça se voit pas mais ça c'est la
magie du spectacle sur scène oui alors
vous flippez un peu sur votre âge ce que
quand on vous voit on a du mal à
comprendre franchement ou dit liu c'est
pas moi je la met en scène tous les
jours elles existent palio j'ai fait un
sale coup à lier aux gésiers au messager
nous disait yahia il ya dix ans déjà de
ça parce que c'est vrai lyon était la
représentation de l'adolescence elle
avait entre 12 et 14 ans quand je les
choisis c'était mon âge à l'époque dans
une bd de de jean claude forest et elle
était le symbole de l'adolescente
oui et c'est vrai que je ne suis plus le
symbole de l'adolescente avec cinq
enfants
six adolescents 50 ans et au ghana où
est ce que tu as presque vous je ne
critique pas le ghana je tiens à le dire
je veux pas d'histoires je ne critique
pas gala est-ce que vous avez vous dit
j'ai du mal à me voir vieillir j'ai la
mécanique s'affaiblit ce n'est jamais
très agréable
oui c'est vrai et c'est jamais très
agréable de devoir les heureux les
regards des hommes toujours attiré par
la jeunesse mais moi vous êtes très
attirante mais vous êtes une femme dans
la plénitude la wii non il faut pas
flipper lalliot n'ont peut-être cesser
c'est comme ça c'est sans doute une
étape obligée du succès très jeune avec
un personnage de lolita effectivement
banana split et tout ça mais quand on
vous voit là écouter thierry moi je
crois une chose je crois que on se voit
énormément
le regard que l'homme que vous aimez
portent sur vous et je crois que quand
le regard qu'on reçoit est quelque chose
qui vous a faibli qu'yves qui vous
remettent tellement en question et sur
des choses qui sans doute sont ridicules
moi je trouve ça une perte d'énergie
totale mais la vérité est que ça moi ça
me marque il ya des choses qui m'ont
marqué c'est vrai que je me regarde plus
dans la glace avec la même le même la
même désinvolture disons ce que moi je
ne me suis jamais regarder dans la glace
avec attention j'étais désinvolte et je
la perds au port et c'est une peur qui
vient alors je mange je mendie tourner
très vite mais je crois que je crois que
c'est sale tout simplement je crois
qu'on ne vieillit jamais quand les gens
n'ont rien les gens là moi je vous dire
de ce jeu bien plus âgée que vous
problème c'est que dans la tête on vit
pas vraiment mais le corps vie et puis
après des gens les gens me croient pas
quand elle redit sa visite quand même
j'ai hâte d'être une vieille dame
indigne 8e passé le cadre de l'antre 2
jamais aimé avoir le cul entre deux
êtres haut niveau après c'est vrai qu'on
a envie à un moment de se dire ouais a
fini à un moment on se dit la vieillesse
il faut que ça serve à ne plus rien
avoir à [ __ ] de rien au moins cet
avantage là c'est ça et de pouvoir faire
plein de conneries et puis personne ne
veut venir vous dire quelle conne ça
c'est génial ça c'est un moment que
j'attends avec la nature merci milo
donc on s'est tous les soirs certains
soirs il est fort quand le lundi soir et
à des matinées samedi le voit c'est aux
folies bergères endroit que nous
connaissons bien alors maintenant on va
rallumer la lumière
marc lavoine l'heure est venue de nous
démontrer vos connaissances musicales
mon cher ami
c'est tout le monde peut jouer voilà
alors comme votre chanson comme si les
tournesols on affaire blind test on a
fait un bide
[Musique]
prentice alors on a fait un blind test
avec des chansons tout le monde peut
jouer avec des chansons qui ont des noms
de fleurs
ça vous rappelle des souvenirs liés aux
les blinds oui c'est tout petit on
travaille sur une bd chaîne alors
première chanson didier s'il vous plaît
dans son ami bien peu de chagny la rose
et moult hormis la violence par kelly
voilà un point pour michèle bernier
natacha bénard mais attention le blind
ps renaud je vous explique j'espère que
c'est à laurent françoise hardy
françoise hardy laurent bourgnon sur vos
bateaux vous avez la radio la musique
indispensable à toute sa journée à
caisse vous écoutez moi un peu de tout
un peuple
bon alors là non mais tout le monde peut
jouer dans l'intérêt du brent et s'est
trouvée dès les premières mesures alors
2e deuxième disque oui le tiers monde
entier l'amour est un bouquet de
violettes très bien alors maintenant on
passe à la troisième et là je dois dire
que vous avez une avance considérable
michèle bernier troisième chanson didier
s'il vous plaît magnolias for ever un
club qui est ce qu a répondu là c'est la
basse et marc cherry
c'est marseille voilà suivant tuer sinon
c'est vraiment vous faire
[Musique]
les roses blanches jolie maman lectrice
est essentielle
c'est une panne et chanson réaliste mais
c'est simplement la chanson préférée de
la langue de votre grand-mère important
chanson suivante monsieur didier
attention on ne souffle pas n'importe où
on a même usé la suivante monsieur
didier agents comme petit coquelicot
bravo monsieur bernier je suis là si
vous trouvez les deux suivantes
voilà trouver la session attention
monsieur didier tension
[Musique]
j'aime bien mon père j'aime bien mais
quand l'amour ma passion j'aime la
mortagne le bord de la mer et les bouts
de londres la charcutière jusqu'ici oui
la gare salah
assez gonflé
on annonce la cible alors là franchement
c'est bien ça s'appelle j'aime pas les
rhododendrons et ccim actuellement la
suivante encore plus dur j'ai rien y
sommes c'est dick annegarn du sort
réservé sur le cas des genres à
connaître hubert félix thiéfaine beau
ben oui oui vous aussi oui d'accord non
pas moins bon et la dernière chanson
attention
[Musique]
à l'elysee la réserve lacroix mots je
pense que tout le monde
ouais mais michèle bernier mais je suis
une discothèque moi j'adorais ça ma
soeur je regardais toutes les émissions
de guy lux
parce que mon père me les interdisait ah
oui c'est exact c'est ma part comme les
droitiers comme marc maintenant des
droits devant vous j'ai encore un
travail à la grogne des juges rouges ils
me voyaient rentrée regarder je
regardais le palmarès de la chanson les
trucs comme ça le jeu de la chance
disait attentes et ses trucs et je
passais mon temps à essayer de regarder
ça évidemment
alors maintenant je vais accueillir
richer soviets cette affiche un bon jour
lancry charme a voulu vous donner la
parole parce que vous avez été victime
samedi dernier lors de la cérémonie des
7 d'or
je dirais pas d'une injustice mais enfin
d'un truc qui ressemble pas trop à la
justice donc ce que je vais dire d'abord
c'est que vous êtes responsable d'une
télévision qui s'appelle télé bocal un
oui à une révision on peut dire
alternative associative en tous les cas
qui n'est pas dans l'établissement de la
télévision
vous êtes aussi avec pierre carles
fiszbin dans la coordination des médias
libres parce que finalement il ya des
fréquences hertziennes qui sont
disponibles et on veut bien les données
lagardère aux biens donnés à bouygues
vient donner à vivendi
mais quand un autre citoyen dit moi je
vais faire ma télé en lui dit non voilà
donc ça c'est pas franchement la
démocratie c'est clair puisque on voit
pas très bien pourquoi pas seulement où
ces gens là peuvent racheter tf1 pour 6
milliards de francs pourquoi vous vous
auriez pas vous demandez rien à personne
en plus vous n'avez pas le droit de
faire une télé voilà alors il ya une
main vous allez organiser une
manifestation symbolique aux sept d'or 1
devant les 7 d'or et c'était prévu pour
être sur le toit du rex pendant les 7
d'or mais nous on avait aussi envoyé
quelqu'un à 7 d'or c'est patricia
gaillot donc avant d'en venir à votre
problème
on va voir elle alors patricia elle
était à l'intérieur du rex vous vous
êtes malheureusement l'extérieur
malheureusement pour vous et elle était
à l'intérieur du rex a été distribuée à
tous nos amis de la télévision les
looser d'or les losers d'or ils ont tous
été ravis qu'on les films saw fins et
julien courbet et on ne rit pas quand je
dis julien courbet s'il vous plaît lui
dis donc j'ai été filmé samedi soir lors
de la cérémonie des 7 d'or par l'une de
vos journalistes
malheureusement il m'est impossible
d'accepter la diffusion de ces images
c'est d'humour julien courbet alors
maintenant on va regarder le magnéto
serge s'il te plaît tentez pas de vue
des stades et donc tu m'auras pas les
dom tom est un trophée
oui c'est annabelle trophée ce qu'elle
sait on nous endort comme tu es petit tu
l'as pas tant d'avoir sept à dix ans je
suis ravie franchement et je trouve
qu'ils me va bien et qu'un tiers des
remerciements ouais bah les
remerciements c'est à tous ceux qui
crachent dessus mais voilà regarder
merci
ça m'a un peu vous et moi c'est un
trophée qu'ils sont militants c'est bon
je vais le
je vis le chérir et je vais essayer
d'être digne de ce
there d'or et de loose et à chaque fois
un grenier merci
gémenos en oubliant la mesure heureux de
nous remettre le loser dorment
attendiez sympa du tout pas du tout
méchant c'est thibault sont pressentis
fortement mais je suis très toute ma vie
je fais ce métier pour avoir secoué
toute ma vie j'en ai rêvé larmes aux
yeux et regardez pas ce que tu peux plus
faire le coin à l'autre
je garde dans la rue tu as compris je
garde elle appela bon pour les autres
finalement les autres ppda patrick nous
sommes en
venez vous offrir le loser d'or puisque
on a vous n'avez pas eu
le scep tort
le jt non mais j'ai eu des conversations
que le charmant de vivienne
ça se fait et je suis déjà comblé sur
les chances d'endosser le loser dos est
ce que vous y attendiez vraiment ce que
c'est
j'ai fait beaucoup d'efforts pour le
mériter pendant treize ans de suite
c'est le perdant gorce
il est magnifique mais c'est moi
quelques remerciements jouets remercier
ma famille équipe c'est moi en plus vous
avez plus à nancy racing vraiment mais
la région est ce que je peux toucher
beaucoup aimé l'attention batma la viola
ils tiennent bien y avait perdu lettieri
c'est vrai que en plus t'es vachement
bien sûr la statue tiens voilà
à l'intérieur du rec samedi
on distribue et comme dit notre ami
foucault les perdants de ces jeunes il
bien le français monsieur fukui bon en
charge est là donc vous vous étiez d'or
vouliez mettre donc depuis le toit du
rex ami michel fiszbin s'était introduit
dans le rex pour placer un émetteur sur
le toit et la boue il a été contrôlé par
l'un des vigiles qui a appelé les forces
se donner pour monter sur le toit dur et
que je les fais sauter un cadenas quand
même oui mais qu'il a remplacé il
remplace le lien si vous facturer des
banques vous remettez les serrures à
bâle c'est moins grave mais ça va donc
c'est vrai donc il a été contrôlé par
leurs contrôles d'identité à tous tout
le tintouin
et alors vous avez été interpellé vous
oui à un journaliste de libé a été
interpellé en juin du parisien était
intervenue lé tout à fait ça surréaliste
je vous dis qu'on puisse très haut
pouvoir franchement non mais c'est vrai
laisser faire des tubes alors quand vous
avez dit que vous aviez une carte de
presse
enfin home où les gens on a dû rien les
flics répondre quand je vous le dis
c'est que vous montrez une carte de
presse à un flic qui répond rien à
[ __ ] voilà ça fait moche et pas la
peine d'avoir moi j'en ai pas finalement
c'est pareil alors vous avez été obligé
de convoquer oui le 18 novembre au
tribunal pour résistance avec violence
et c'est exactement ce que fait votre
grand-père à ce que fait de policiers
qui ont porté plainte contre moi bien
sûr y en avait 1 120 kg un autre de 80
kg ce jour là j'avais dû la potion
magique donc la volonté des flux c'est
ce qu'il aura que vous êtes celle ci
raconte en fait alors j'ai pu j'ai
beaucoup de témoins évidemment puisqu'il
y avait comme tu le disais il ya un
journaliste de libération et le parisien
et tout le monde s'est embarqué tous les
journalistes se sont fait remarquer
carte de presse ou non avant de regarder
le sujet donc sur la sphère en question
donc c'est le soir ou la gaffe contre
qui nous n'avons rien a été élu
personnalité de l'année en télévision et
je vais citer pierre desproges qui
disait la démocratie c'est la victoire
de belmondo sur fellini magnéto
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui s'est passé
alors écoute chez pas il ya un gars
ils ont abattu deux solos et allez
lâchez moi mais lâchez moi vous aimez
comme ça il n'est pas bien on est tous
là
[Musique]
alors foncez
on à l'appartement qui est en passe de
mcdo musée de la ba juste pour peu qu'on
m'a pris récemment deux sens l'a10 et
prévu là on l'a fait là on y va
qu'est ce qui va faire encore un pas
passé ils veulent pas laisser passer
vraiment c'est délit de sale gueule
sans leader de la dictature et qui parce
qu'il a cette télévision qui pour leur
soirée à 2000 personnes vont casser la
gueule là tout à toute la population
eh bien nous sommes en ce moment au
boulevard bonne nouvelle ou une horde de
csp crs protège donc les gens de la
télévision
donc on peut considérer que les gens de
la télévision a besoin des crs pour
exister ici à coup les médias lourds et
là-bas tff en bloc le quartier nous on
utiliserait mètres carrés c'est ça la
liberté d'expression quelle impression
ça vous fait d'assister aux sept d'or
justement la télévision géante où c'est
comme toutes ces cérémonies il filme
exactement pareil nhra décor de luxe
avec les mêmes têtes toujours les mêmes
qu'on voit qu'on revoie partir d'une
manifestation comme ça il faut qu'ils
nous contre manifestation mais ce qui
est formidable c'est qu'ils en train de
se faire là tu crois que là yvan ils
vont réduire le cercle encore il nous
laissait donc dans le cercle produit
quand même
alors par l'esprit
méfiez-vous
ou alors vous allez recommencer le même
mec c'est vrai il est vrai
la chine attend alors
donc c'était pas son ex
samedi dernier face au rex il faut qu'en
france on est l'un des derniers pays à
ne pas avoir de télévision associative
de libre accès donc il serait peut-être
temps qu'on y vienne et moi j'ai
interpelle les sénateurs puisque le
projet de loi est en train de faire est
en train de naviguer entre le sénat et
le parlement et donc on a proposé des
amendements et donc je propose attendait
c'est dans ce sens qui truquent les
charpentes hara kiri j'arrive 200
devenus des journaux culte c'était parce
que c'était des coups de poing l'emmener
à chaque fois voilà tant que ça reste un
truc qu'on essaye je suis désolé d'être
gentil d'aller c'est d'appeler les gens
de leur ca marche pas ça marche puisque
là il fait changer la loi
l'association n'est pas reconnue comme
une structure qui ont fait que ça
pourrait sembler richard
je vous en supplie ne demandez pas à
renault quelle que soit la sympathie que
j'ai pour vous tant qu'ils sont pas au
pouvoir
ils sont d'accord avec vous le jour ils
sont au pouvoir ses fils mesdames
messieurs je voudrais vous montrer une
cassette on se dépêche on n'a plus le
temps jusqu'à cinq ans avec vous ce soit
clair je n'ai qu'à ses débuts dans le
sujet dont vous connaissez une famille
pas vu pas pris de pierre carles qui a
été interdite par canal+ qui est en
vente à partir du mois de novembre voilà
aussi je me dire qu'on laisse pour lens
notre chaîne hertzienne le 16 octobre
donc vous pouvez vous captez télé bocal
sur le canal 38 canal 38 télé locale
sans autorisation bien sûr puisqu'on l'a
pas obtenu du csa donc on sera pirates
on ira jusqu'à la cd vous savez
mitterrand avait circulaire s'il vous
plaît faites des trucs bien
maintenant je demande à serge khalfon
c'est la fin d'émission
c'est le moment important de l'émission
je demande qu'on baisse la lumière
[Musique]
basket et d'en cas
voilà la pochette du disque c'est
extrême
ciel septième album
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fragile font de nous voir ton 10 tonnes
je crois frais
la fin espérances de brno
qu'on n'oublie pas
faire
nos idées
plus belle la vie du sang joie les
lèvres jamais reçu celle jamais
et pourquoi je vous laisse un peu
ban
[Musique]
on joue là
après
condé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et tournesol
chine le champ de blé
[Musique]
michaud
et
[Musique]
un splash en ligne
saisissons la com
mais
mais on est
un petit dire
que libertine
[Musique]
possible
de santé
encore quelque chose de chaud
[Musique]
et comme un rouge et les choses
g
le blé
n'est ce pas
[Musique]
départ
mr deh
[Musique]
chez nous
doublé
[Musique]
en
il était
shankar
mardi 2
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bravo merci martin valent les tournesols
très bonnes chances sont très bonnes
chansons il a fait la musique avec
carillon bravo mariata soir merci
beaucoup
ben voilà comment on dit là c'est fini
alors marc lavoine les tournesols
michèle bernier le démon de midi donc
s'ils voulaient passer une bonne soirée
vous marrer moi je les ai vus je vous
garantis c'est super long terme en 2010
en tournée dans toute la france
laurent bourgnon donc le 17 octobre sur
le bateau alors moi je me suis jamais
intéressé aux courses de voiliers tout
ça là maintenant je vous connais je vais
regarder je vais regarder toute la
journée savoir où et si vous êtes
premier ou deuxième
d'accord on va s'appliquer pour pour la
toux soutenir laurent bourgnon lio donc
folies bergères sept garçons et sept
filles 1
comédie musicale une vraie comédie
musicale renaud muselier si vous êtes
rpr voter pour lui oui si vous êtes paix
rhdp en beauté par une façon on est même
en beauté et richard alors à richard se
liait de télé bocal c'est quand c'est
son canal produite le 16 octobre canal
38 le 16 octobre maintenant
apportez moi voilà linda hardy 25 ans
demain ma chérie
merci j'ai fait comme on en parle
prochaine émission la semaine prochaine
merci et à samedi
visible
ciao
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]